in depth book TVs three-hour live
interview program is next author and new
yorker staff writer jane mayer talks
about her books and takes your questions
she's the author of bestsellers
landslides strange justice the dark side
and dark money
author jane mayer when we talk about the
koch brothers who are we talking about
well we're talking about interestingly
two of the richest people in the world
probably the richest pair of brothers in
the world certainly in america who are
very strong political views and have
taken their fortune over the last 40
years to try to influence america
they've spent in very targeted ways and
interesting ways to try to change the
whole direction of american politics
what are their names where they look at
it
so there's charles koch and david koch
are the ones that people think of as the
koch brothers and charles lives in
Wichita Kansas which is where the family
company Koch Industries is based and
David lives in New York he is the
wealthiest resident in Manhattan there
actually are two other Koch brothers
people don't talk about them much
there's Bill Koch and there's Fred Koch
and you hear about them in my book but
mostly you don't hear about them much in
the headlines why not they're not as
political as Charles and David and in
some ways they are losers in a huge
family struggle that took place over the
years there was this epic kind of
dynastic struggle in the family for who
was going to control the family company
Koch Industries it's a huge privately
owned company that the cokes have have
joked about for years is the biggest
company no one's ever heard of it's a
company though that almost every
American probably comes into contact
with you don't know you do probably but
if you buy Dixie Cups Stainmaster carpet
lycra Vanity Fair napkins Georgia
Pacific lumber and so many other
products you are a consumer of coke
industries and there was this epic fight
among these four boys for who was going
to have control of this company that the
father Fred Koch started and the two
that lost out were the ones you don't
hear about very much and those are Fred
and Bill what do Fred and Bill do so
they're very interesting bill started up
his own business that
is also in fossil fuels the part of the
coke industries I failed to mention is
probably the biggest part of it which is
it's in fossil fuels it refines oil and
it has coal and gas and so Bill Koch is
in has his own company that actually
sells a different kind of coke it's a
byproduct of refining oil and Fred is a
kind of shy philanthropist who is very
interested in the arts and gives money
to all kinds of cultural institutions
but mostly anonymously which is very
interesting because the other brothers
are quite splashy like to get attention
and David Koch's name is known to
everybody in New York City because it's
emblazoned on so many institutions that
he funds but he likes to get attention
for it whereas the his older brother
fred is quite quiet about it when you
refer to fred is artistic are you saying
he's gay
well you know he I wouldn't say that I
would know because fred has said himself
that he's not gay
his brothers have accused him of being
gay over the years and they in fact
tried at one point according to a
document that I described in this book
it's a sealed court document that
describes under oath testimony from Bill
Koch one of the brothers you don't hear
about much about how he and his two
other brothers tried to frame their
older brother Fred they said they called
him to a meeting that they said was a
company meeting in fact it was a
kangaroo court
where they had their older brother walk
in he was in his 20s at that point and
they were too and they said they were
going to tell their father he was gay
and unless he turned over his shares in
the company
to these other brothers and so it was an
attempt to kind of blackmail him about
what they claimed was his private life
his private life has remained private
and so I don't really feel it's my role
in life to try to out people who may be
gay or may not be gay I'd like to give
him the right to decide
what kind of zone of privacy he wants to
live in but I think it's too bad his own
brothers didn't show that same kind of
respect and it's it's it's an insight
into this family this is a rough tough
ruthless bunch of people oh and this is
the story I tell in the book about these
these these family members and they they
went to mat the mat against each other I
mean the idea that you might try
blackmailing your own brother and and
say you're going to tell your father and
they told the older brother also that
the father would disinherit him if he
found out the older brother didn't
buckle under he knew his brothers well
he'd grown up with them and seen years
of their sort of rough tactics he stood
up and Fred walked out of the room
before he did he said I don't want to
ever hear about this again he didn't
actually get treated the same by the
family in terms of inheritance but he
walked out on that and you know in
recent years David Koch has said that he
is a supporter of gay rights even though
if people think of them as vastly
conservative but they're they're not
really social conservatives they're
libertarians so it may be that David
Koch's changed his views on this since
these earlier --zz many people in the
country have changed their views about
gay rights but it was a brutal
confrontation between brothers over get
grabbing the family fortune Jane Muir
how does a reporter and author get ahold
of a sealed court document like with
lots and lots and lots of trying I you
know there's certain things that I can't
really talk about how I got the
documents I have but you can see that
nobody has challenged the the
authenticity of it since this books come
out and there are new documents in this
book and it took a long time to put this
book together I was up against a lot to
try to get the information but I as a
reporter think that court documents are
one of the most kind of unassailable
kinds of facts you can bring to the
public in dark money the hidden history
of the billionaire's behind the rise of
the radical right were you able to
interview any of the Koch fan
members well I wish I could talk more
about the people I was able to interview
who do not want to be discussed I can't
really talk about that in great detail
but I can say that neither neither David
Koch nor Charles Koch spoke to me and I
did try for quite a few years in fact I
think for about five years I kept you
know if I drop an email to somebody who
worked with them or talked to people I
know who know them and try to get an
interview and they've they've got a long
history of secrecy so there's just kind
of a family saying that Charles Koch
quotes sometimes and he says that his
father used to say it's when the whale
spouts that he gets harpooned and so for
that reason they he is preferred to swim
under the surface so the story that I
tell here is mostly a story that these
people really did not want told and they
certainly didn't want to help me tell it
oddly enough you write in dark money the
fiercely libertarian Koch family owed
part of its fortune to two of history's
most famous dictators Joseph Stalin and
Adolf Hitler isn't that remarkable these
are the maybe the country's foremost
libertarian influences sort of supposed
to be anti-authoritarian yet the
family's fortune began when the father
Fred Koch who was apparently a very
bright man an early graduate of MIT
figured out a better way to crack oil to
turn it into refine it and he had this
breakthrough but he couldn't sell it in
America because he felt the major oil
companies were blocking him they had
kind of a monopoly and so he had to take
it elsewhere if he was going to make
money so ironically the place he went
first was the Soviet Union and he went
to Stalin and he built of something like
15 oil refineries for Stalin in the
first five-year plan of Stalin's Soviet
Union and then Stalin realized you know
he could get his own people to design
these they could copy it so Fred Koch
was kind of out of business there and
looking further for where he could go he
then helped design one of the most
important refineries in Nazi Germany it
was he got the Commission in 1933
started building in 1934 it was
completed in 1935 so at this point by
then you know people who are watching
sort of the rise of Hitler Hitler became
the Chancellor of the Third Reich in
1933 Hitler is is is you know in control
of Germany at this point and a lot of
bad things are beginning to happen but
Fred Koch was making money and this
refinery that was built there by Koch
who was then called Winkler Koch on one
other partner had to be personally
green-lighted by Hitler at first
Hitler's henchmen said they didn't want
this American refinery Hitler said he
wanted it he okayed it and it became key
to the Nazi war efforts it was a very
advanced refinery that could refine high
octane fuel that was necessary for the
Air Force and Hitler was trying to build
up his military at this point and saw
the possibilities and this refinery
became a very big part of the Nazi war
effort the US and Allies bombed it
several times because it was a key
target during World War two and
according to reports that came out after
my book in between the bombings it was
rebuilt by slave labor by the by people
whom the Nazis concentration camps who
had to put it back together again so I
mean it's a story of it's an ironic
interesting twist on one of America's
biggest companies great companies Koch
Industries a kind of a hidden history
that again is part of the story that I
tell that they didn't necessarily want
the world to know how important is it
that Koch Industries is privately held I
think as you know and I I think it's
very important I'm not maybe one of the
world's experts on business but I did
start my career spending twelve years at
the Wall Street Journal and so I covered
this and the difference between a public
and a private company is that it's it
first of all the private company is
accountable mostly to the its owners and
in this case that's principally almost
exclusively these two brothers so
they've been able to plow their money
back into it over and over again instead
of trying to show immediate gains for
stockholders this has helped them make
it very successful it's phenomenally
successful this company so it's been
great for them financially and it's kept
it out of the public eye so it's been
kind of a secretive company that doesn't
have to answer to many people how long
did you work on this book and where did
you get the interest in the right I was
working on this book if you start I
still it started with a magazine piece
for The New Yorker where I'm a staff
writer and I did that into the in 2010
so I suppose you could say it's been
five years or something like that though
it wasn't I wasn't working exclusively
on the book the whole time maybe the
last three years I was working on it
exclusively and my interest in the write
it pretty much is serendipitous it comes
from my my career of as a reporter in
Washington in in 1983 The Wall Street
Journal brought me to Washington to
cover the Reagan White House and I
started in 1984 the very beginning it
was the the Reagan's reelection campaign
so I've lived through this period and
I've watched these were my sources many
of the people who in these books I've
written were the people I interviewed I
saw and what interested me and part of
the reason I wrote the dark money is
that when I started that many years ago
these people were on the fringe
these were people Reagan was president
but there were always these people that
were on the far-right fringe who I'd
call because they were interesting for a
counterpoint than comments and they were
people who are interested in ideas often
but they were way out there and I mean
and in his example and don't take my
word for it I mean there's a quote in
the beginning
of dark money where William F Buckley
describes the the movement that the
cokes were part of as a narco to talat
Aryans
they were the part of the far-right that
the Conservatives were trying to purge
because they thought they were kind of
the lunatic fringe and so what
interested me by the time I wrote this
book was they'd gained so much power
that they in some ways had become the
center of gravity in the Republican
Party I mean there's a new there's a new
study out from Harvard that this is by
theta Scotch poll and another professor
there who described the coke its coke
effect and they say it is a magnetic a
magnetic pull on the Republican Party
that is sort of pulled the whole party
with them so I was interested well how
did they get from way out there to the
center of Republican politics and in
many ways the center of American
politics is the coke political network
in your view stronger than the
Republican National Committee yeah I
think today I mean they're they're in
competition in some ways but they're
also they're in some ways what's
happened is the coke network has
subsumed the Republican Party so the
positions that Republican candidates
take are often the positions that the
cokes take the cokes have the money and
they offer the campaign funding and
other support from all the different
groups they have two candidates who will
champion their positions so as an
example right now in the Republican
field of presidential primary candidates
all of the major candidates have come to
the cokes to ask for their financial
backing and so they're kind of sort of
kissing their ring to some extent
there's one candidate who is the
exception and that's Donald Trump and
he's made the most of it I mean he's
called the others puppets and he's
playing to the crowd saying I own myself
every all the others are owned and it's
it's it's become you know dynamic in
this campaign from dark money what made
the Koch family's growing financial role
in American politics extraordinary
was the way that it merged all forms of
political spending into one investment
aimed at paying huge future dividends to
the donors well that is true and the
cokes in particular have a kind of a
force magnifier it's not just that they
are among the richest people in the
world which of course in itself adds a
certain amount of clout to their
political ambitions but they've been
very smart as have the other families I
write about in dark money about using
philanthropy the idea that that these
wealthy families have private
foundations that they can give money to
and take tax deductions so they're
subsidized basically by the public
treasury and with those foundations they
push their ideology and that ideology
they push pushes their interests they're
almost like lobbying operations but
they're tax deductible and each of these
families that I described has done that
in different ways and and it you know so
what you've got with the cokes is people
who can give money through a huge
corporation through a gigantic private
family fortune and through a network of
philanthropic groups that echo their
message all across the country and and
it's that third prong in some ways that
made them so interesting and so
important how is that different though
than a George Soros or a Tom Styer on
the left doing the same thing through
their donations in some ways I think
steyr probably got in to try to
counterbalance some of this he's kind of
a johnny-come-lately to this one thing
that he does is his money that he gives
is disclosed money the books called dark
money because it's about money that is
given behind the scenes by people who
don't want you to see the fingerprints
on it and so in order to hide their
money trail the cokes and some of the
others give money to these kind of
philanthropic groups that don't show who
the dome
are there called 501c floors and they're
supposed to not be principally in
politics that's debatable I would say so
this is about that game in particular
and how important it's become I'm Soros
he gives some of that money in an
undisclosed way through an organization
at least he has in the past called the
tides foundation so he's engaged to some
extent in some of this he I did do a big
piece about Soros and you know when you
when you write about the cokes in this
country inevitably what you hear about
from since they are on the right is
people saying why don't you write about
Soros so we must will get this on the
table I wrote about Sorrows I wrote a
very long piece in The New Yorker about
Soros in 2004 which was the year that he
truly started putting serious money into
electoral politics and and I wrote all
about him and when after that election
he was very disappointed he didn't get
what he wanted he was trying to defeat
george w bush's reelection and he was
through from electoral politics somewhat
the reason i'm focusing on the cokes
they've stepped up their role in
electoral politics they are currently
putting together a jackpot that they
themselves have described as having 889
million dollars potentially in it for
this 2016 election cycle
at its height George Soros spent
something like 20 million dollars of his
own money so we're talking about 20
million versus 889 million dollars even
with inflation between 2004 and now
you're talking about a kind of money in
a few hands that nobody's seen in this
country before Jane Barron will come
show some video and you'll know what it
is and this is something you write about
in your book very soon after I
discovered that actually there had been
a kind of an opposition research project
on me and that the couple of top people
at Koch Industries in Washington had
organized it and they had hired a
private eye who turned out to be the
police commissioner in New York City
Howard safer and that the former police
commissioner not current
like with his son and a daughter who had
been in the FBI and they have a private
firm in New York and I eventually pieced
together the story just as a reporter
would and was found a source who told me
they were looking for a dirt dirt dirt
and if they couldn't find it they'd make
it up and so they'd had actually made
something up they came to they put
together a story saying that I was a
plagiarist and they tried to peddle it
to a couple news organizations neither
which would run it because it turned out
not to be true but it would have been
pretty terrible if it didn't and to
print and anyone believed it luckily
nobody ran with it Jane Mayer what was
that about yeah that was about the cokes
hiring well let's be careful about this
top people at Koch Industries working in
Washington put together a boiler room
operation in which they worked with a
private eye in New York City to dig up
dirt on me
and they spent quite a few months
looking for anything that they could use
to discredit me I'm not alone in this
there there are many instances in this
book of the Koch specifically hiring
private eyes to try to dig up dirt on
people who challenged them I mean they
have an awful lot of unaccountable power
their private they've got a huge private
company they're trying to play a major
role in America's public life but from
behind the scenes and they don't really
like it when one shines a big light on
them and that's what I was trying to do
you say that boiler room was set up in
former congressman JC Watts lobbying
office that's right it was sort of as
some extra space in the back room there
I I eventually it took some time but
eventually was able to get a pretty good
picture of what was going on and it was
extraordinary in my experience I've got
to say I've covered a lot of things but
I have not as far as I know been that
the target of an effort to discredit me
that was quite like that and I mean
maybe I should be flattered on some day
you know level I mean that anyone would
take a reporter so seriously but it was
it could have been scary it was scary
and
whay you know I mean it's it felt like
an effort to ruin me and I think if they
had succeeded in convincing people that
I was plagiarizing I mean for a reporter
that's that's a crime of moral turpitude
it does it's something that could take
you down and so it was not a minor kind
of effort it was a killer effort I'm
very glad it didn't succeed and my
colleagues from whom I was supposed to
have plagiarized were fantastic and
stood up to defend me and said this is
not true one of them looked at one of
the stories I was supposed to have
stolen it was a Washington Post reporter
and he said not only did you not steal
from me you credited me in the next
friggin sentence so you know it was it
was a badly done operation in some ways
but it's unusual and it gives you an
insight into the hardball that these two
brothers who want so much power over
American politics have played where did
the title the dark side your 2008 book
come from the dark sides title came from
the former Vice President Dick Cheney in
he went on the air himself so shortly
after 9/11 and he said you know in order
to win this war on terror we're going to
need to play kind of on the dark side
and and it was unclear what he was
talking about at that point what did the
dark side mean but the book explains
what that tie what that title what that
term was talking about did you ever meet
Vice President Cheney or interview him
for the book I you know I I certainly
have met Vice President Cheney and had a
chance to talk to him I didn't he did
not give me the interview for the book I
hate for a little while I had a the the
answer to my interview request up on my
bulletin board I said could you talk to
me anytime in the next two years and the
answer came back from an assistant who
said unfortunately Vice President Cheney
it will be very busy during the next two
years so that was a kind of a blanket no
but I
had a chance to see him since we
actually were in a green room together
at one point going on ABC together and
it was just the two of us sitting there
having our makeup put on and it was it
was great to have a chance to talk to
him he had said he commented on some of
the things in the book that seemed as if
he'd at least read some of it which was
flattering and and we talked about our
Labrador Retrievers which we share a
great you know love for Jane Muir this
is a it's a complicated story which was
the darks the dark side the dark side is
a very complicated story
all of these are complicated stories
really I mean if I look back on these
books I think they're in a way efforts
to kind of stop the clock everybody you
know I'm a reporter we all see the
headlines we all can read a story that's
maybe a few inches long 20 inches long
in the newspapers they're all efforts to
say whoa
you know there's so much more going on
here and the only way I can do it is
take a leave of absence from my day job
and write dig down deep and put this
whole story together and explain what
was really going on behind the curtains
so that's what these books are kind of
an effort to do you write the lead
architect of the Bush administration's
idiosyncratic interpretation of American
law was a tall and B speckled government
lawyer who had the look of an irascible
sea captain david addy that was david
addington who is a fascinating character
and a true believer again a lot of these
characters that I've written about here
are people who who kind of fit that the
quote that that justice brand Louis
Brandeis talked about they are there's
there's elet's they're men they're
people who are true believers who in
some ways even though they feel pure of
heart are you know what brand I says is
in some ways many of these people are
dangers more than than sort of the you
know the scoundrels they they are such
true believers that they
kind of can take the country right off
the cliff and Addington was a true
believer in executive power and secrecy
and he was in a position to help guide
the Bush administration into authorizing
a war on terror that was fought really
much behind closed doors through covert
operations using tactics that if they
were public might have been very
controversial jeanmaire so that Joe
Wilson Valerie Plame's Scooter Libby
story was that a sideshow to all of this
in a sense yeah I mean I don't think it
was terribly much in in the central area
of all of this you know Scooter Libby
was a native of Vice President Cheney
and he was an important advisor but I
don't think that that was that I mean it
was not the major story of what was
going on during that period strange
justice going into that book did you
believe in Nita Hill going into that
book I wrote this with my friend Jill
Abramson who had been a friend since
high school
we were both reporters at the Wall
Street Journal at that point and I I
wasn't really sure you really couldn't
tell exactly who was telling the truth I
don't know if you watched the hearings
during that period I spent the weekend
glued to my television set completely
floored I had covered courts before that
earlier on in my career and it was
really like a good trial where with two
good lawyers were both sides when they
take the stand you think they're right
they must be telling the truth because
they were so convincing both sides were
so sure of themselves and so convincing
so I wasn't really sure what we would
find I thought from the start I think
that that Clarence Thomas had more
reason to to lie because he was trying
to get a job that he wanted and trying
to you know it was hard to see what
there was in this for Anita Hill I mean
it didn't seem that she wasn't trying to
get something out of this so I mean
there seem to be more motive for one
side but
I thought both sides were very
convincing at when they did their first
initial hearings and so what Jill and I
did was we drew up a list of many many
people we needed to speak to if possible
and the idea was to figure out if we
could find out who was telling the truth
because the conventional wisdom when we
began was that this was what they were
calling a he-said she-said story where
you know you'll never get to the bottom
of it and you can't really tell who's
telling the truth and for reporters that
did serve except that it means accepting
the idea that you can't get the truth
and that's kind of like waving a red
flag in front of a bull I mean we were
feeling like oh yeah there is some way
to get to the bottom of this and figure
out what the truth is there's always
some way and the truth comes out over
time it really does and so we decided to
see if we could find out and it took us
three years but I think we got close
here's a little bit from that hearing
this is a circus it's a national
disgrace
and from my standpoint as a black
American as far as I'm concerned it is a
high-tech lynching for uppity blacks who
in any way deign to think for themselves
to do for themselves to have different
ideas and it is a message that unless
you count to an old order this is what
will happen to you you will be lynched
destroyed caricatured by a committee of
the u.s. US Senate rather than hung from
a tree Wow
it still has huge power doesn't it you
know that was the that was just nuclear
language that Clarence Thomas was using
for a black man to sit in front of a
panel of white senators and say you're
lynching me and and saying you're doing
it because I am trying to rise from my
from a lowly position because I'm uppity
it's about the most powerful thing he
could have come up with it's playing the
ultimate victim card basically and it's
also if you look at it what he's doing
is not talking at all about the facts
that Anita Hill brought forward he's
just plain saying you are lynching me
and it was it that was a turning point
in those hearings it was at that point
that even the the Liberal Democratic
senators kind of what backed off here's
a little bit of a Nita Hill all we've
heard for 103 days is about a most
remarkable man and nobody has come
forward and they scoured his every shred
of life and nobody but you and another
witness apparently who's alleging no
sexual harassment has come forward and
so maybe maybe it seems to me you didn't
really intend to kill him but you might
have
and that's pretty heavy
I don't care if you're a man or a woman
but let me tell you if what you say this
man said to you occurred client God's
name when he left his position of power
or status or authority over you and you
left it in 1983 why in god's name would
you ever speak to a man like that the
rest of your life that was Alan
Simpson's former senator Alan Simpson
that is right he was grilling Anita Hill
and basically accusing her it sounded
like of almost trying to kill Clarence
Thomas at least reputationally she was
grilled in a way that was disgraceful
when you look back on it and she was
accused of being a nerado maniac they
were the people who were trying to tar
her reputation were digging for a dirt
on her that was very interesting they
were talking to psychiatrists they
talked to students who she had taught
who had made a joke out of the fact that
some of that hair from her head had
fallen into one of their term papers and
claimed it was a pubic hair it was a
joke it was an ugly joke but it was you
know kind of making fun of black hair
and they acted as if it was serious as
if it was some kind of sexual thing she
was doing with the students term papers
I mean it's unbelievable when you look
back to see what Anita Hill went through
- and that it was a just a kind of maybe
an important turning point when you look
back to in American politics we're
talking today about how far the
presidential campaign has gotten into
the gutter with some of the language and
things going on right now you can see it
was down deep in the gutter during this
period on it on this this confirmation
hearing of of Clarence Thomas and we've
been in the gutter before and so I think
people sometimes forget that I think
anyway it was it was really it was
really ugly what was your interview with
Anita Hill like well so you know you
asked in the beginning whether we
thought we would exonerate Anita Hill if
that way and that was not the purpose of
the book I think people have to
understand that for Jill Abramson who
became the editor of The New York Times
and for myself as a reporter first at
The Wall Street Journal and now at The
New Yorker
there is one agenda which is to find out
what's true and so when we interviewed
Anita Hill she she had her backup
because we weren't there to say you're
you're wonderful or you were right we
were there to find out what was true and
so we asked her a number of tough
questions and she was a little offended
I think at some points about it I mean
we were really doing our jobs that is
our job and sometimes it ends up with
everybody being offended but in the end
you know we we wound up weighing all the
evidence that we could get and the
evidence was very damning for Clarence
Thomas and was was very supportive of
Anita Hill had it gone the other way we
would have gone the other way because
our reputations and our interest are it
all about telling the truth and so
that's what you know the truth just came
out badly for Clarence Thomas in this
book because the truth comes out badly
I'm afraid Jane Mayer in a Columbia
University oral history that you did in
2013 here's what you had to say about
Jill Abramson and working with her I'm
not surprised at all that she became the
editor of the New York Times her
judgment is amazing and she's a killer
reporter she gets right to the nub of it
and kind of knows what to look for
she has a great nose she's tough she's
tougher than I am
I sort of softened people up and I worry
about how they feel she just goes
playing for the heart of it that is
really true oh she and you know she is
just
amazingly smart also I have to say and
so I've known Jill since high school she
was the class ahead of me at the ethical
culture school in New York City and she
was also a really good dresser
early on so she was she was she's great
we're still very close friends and it
was fun working with her but she and she
helped my reporting a lot because she's
I learned a lot from her but I want to
go to the line
I sort of soften people up and I worry
about how they feel I do I mean and I
don't you know it's funny I don't really
I I suppose being an investigative
reporter people expect you to be a tough
person because I write tough stories but
I don't write them in order to hurt
people's feelings and I don't like
hurting people's feelings I just feel
that my responsibility is to my readers
and to telling what's true and sometimes
that means you're going to have to put
out stories that are going to put people
in a bad light I mean I really don't
enjoy hurting people's feelings in what
we write in ever but it's it's it seems
you know my sense is that my gift is to
be able to try to help the democracy by
getting true and full information out to
people and then they can make up their
own minds but that's really my job and I
feel like it's a helpful job not a
hurtful job Jane Mayer often in stories
we look for good and evil we look for
characters who are bad and characters
who are good and heroes and villains it
I
that's a really broad brush but is that
fair to say that people are heroes or
villains or they're a lot of shades in
there well there are a lot of shades
I mean I've learned a few things in all
these years maybe if reporting and one
is that contrary to what I might have
expected most of the people who do
things that I consider wrong whether in
politics or other things covered crimes
to do they have
tendency to rationalize what they're
doing they're not sitting there thinking
oh I'm going to pull it over on the
public and or I'm going to get away with
this most of them I mean I would imagine
if you interviewed Clarence Thomas today
as if you'd interviewed him then when we
when Jill and I wrote the book I imagine
he somehow thinks he did the right thing
and did nothing wrong and III might
differ with him about how truthful he
was but my guess is he's totally
rationalized it you don't find people
who say I'm gonna lie you find people
who find a way to justify what they're
doing most of the time so it makes it
more of a dark ray then it ends but I do
think you find real heroes I have to say
and the heroes have been among the
things that have really made me feel
good about being a reporter are finding
people who are doing the right thing and
telling their stories so in in the dark
side for instance there are a number of
people who I so admired they were it's
their FBI agents who really loved the
Constitution and the Bill of Rights and
said we're not going to torture people
we are not going to bend the rules in
order to inflict cruel and unusual
punishment on people that's not who we
are in this country we there were there
were CIA officers who felt the same way
there was Alberta Mort Mora who was the
general counsel of the Navy very
conservative former from a partly Cuban
family who had been was the general
counsel the Navy appointed by George W
Bush Alberta Mora because of his
knowledge of Cuba understood how
important human rights are and he just
said we are not going down this path of
throwing people down into its dungeons
without any rights I'm not going there
and he sort of stood up again for the
idea of of the Constitution and these
are people who not left they're not
right they fall all the way across the
spectrum some on the Left were at the
ACLU lawyers who were very brave and got
in very early on to try to say
the no matter how bad those men in
Guantanamo might have been they deserve
lawyers and as human beings they have
some legal rights they won that argument
in front of the Supreme Court it was a
very unpopular argument when they made
it but many people on the right agreed
with them to who were part of this
process
those people's stories are so heartening
to me and they were up against a lot
they were people who who saw their
careers endangered for speaking out so
you know I do think there actually are
heroes and they're often in little
people and big people but would it be
fair to say that Vice President Cheney
David Addington the Koch brothers are
doing what they believe is good for the
country I do think so I think again that
they fall into the category from my
standpoint absolutes these are people
who have views that are in many ways far
out of the American mainstream and
they've so believed that they're right
that sometimes they're willing to go
outside of democracy to get to do what
they want to do so you've got in in and
and you people might wonder what are the
connections between the dark side and
dark money in both cases these books are
about what people do in the dark outside
of the public view in behind closed
doors where they don't disclose what
they're up to and there's not kind of
the sunlight of the press following them
there's a lot of secrecy and stealth in
these people's actions so you've got in
the case of the cokes you have people
who it's interesting in 1980 they tried
the old-fashioned Democratic route to
get what they wanted so David Koch ran
for Vice President of the United States
on the libertarian ticket against Ronald
Reagan from the right because the Koch
brothers felt Reagan was too liberal and
was a sellout and they wanted they had
much more radical views and they didn't
win obviously that election in 1980 in
fact even though David Koch spent
millions of his own dollars to get try
to get elected they got about 1% of the
vote
libertarian ticket after that 1980
Fiasco the Koch brothers stopped trying
to run for office that would have been
the Democratic way to win America over
to its cause for them to keep running
and try to convince the public but they
didn't do that after that election
there's that there's a description in
the history of libertarianism where
Charles Koch basically says that he
thinks politicians are actors and he's
not interested in them because becoming
an actor or having David be an actor
what the Koch brothers want to do is
write the script so they decide from
that point on that they're going to fund
the whole machinery of American politics
and of political thinking to try to
change the script in America from behind
the scenes using philanthropic groups to
fund think tanks to fund university
professors to fund grassroots groups of
people going out in the streets they
they sort of work from behind the scenes
trying to gradually create a kind of a
momentum for their point of view that's
a much sort of sneakier process in the
case of of Cheney and what was happening
during the war on terror what you see is
a small group of people around President
Bush who felt that we needed to go to
the dark side we needed to use methods
that America had not used they needed to
try to do legal torture on people and
they don't let everybody in on this
secret even the people who are in charge
who should have been led in on it like
Colin Powell who has put kept purposely
in the dark because they know he's not
going to support it so they cut people
out and again it's a kind of a backroom
tiny cadre of people who are working to
do things that they know won't be
popular good afternoon and welcome to
book TV on c-span 2 this is our monthly
in-depth program where we talked to one
author and we discuss his or her body of
work this month its author and new
yorker staff writer Jane Mayer who is
our guest he is the author of four
beginning in 1988 with landslide the
unmaking of a president strains justice
came out in 1994 the selling of Clarence
Thomas is a subtitle for that book in
2008 the dark side came out the inside
story of how the war on terror turned
into a war on American ideals those last
two books that we discussed were both
nominated for the National Book Award
and dark money came out in this year the
hidden history of the billionaires
behind the rise of the radical right now
it's your turn we've spent a nearly an
hour talking with Jane Mayer about some
of her books and some of the things and
so you get an idea of what our
conversation is going to be about we
want to hear from you as well
2:02 is the area code for all of our
numbers seven four eight eight two zero
two if you live in the east and central
time zones seven four eight eight two
zero three for those of you in the
mountain and Pacific time zones you can
also email us at book TV at c-span dot
o-r-g you can post a comment on twitter
at book TV and you can make a comment on
our Facebook page facebook.com slash
book TV finally you can send a text
message to Jane Mayer as well and this
is not for telephoning this is simply
for a text message to zero to seven one
seven nine six eight four so if you want
to send a text to zero to seven one
seven nine six eight four and we'll
begin taking those calls in just a few
minutes Jane Mayer we we need to touch
on landslide as well especially with the
passing from Nancy Reagan at ninety four
years old but you tell a story in there
you tell actually two stories about
Nancy Reagan they're kind of one-off
stories readdress and Rekha Vic well the
red dress was just the evening the story
of Reagan calling on me on the red dress
yeah he was um
and you weren't purposefully though I
it's funny I I was at The Wall Street
Journal and I was covering the Reagan
White House and he was going to have a
press conference and we had heard that
he loved red Nancy often or
and so so I wrote a little piece about
how he usually calls on on on people
wearing red especially women wearing red
I actually did not wear a red dress that
day and my bureau chief Alejandra put on
a red dress so I did I went home I
changed I went to the press conference
and there I was in my red dress and
Reagan said called on me right away and
said there's the little girl in the red
dress so I was young I thought it was
funny anyway so I did get cold on that
way he was you could catch his attention
and but Nancy was a great character
really behind the scenes I found when I
was covering the Reagan White House she
was kind of the untold story a lot of
the time she I do tell the story in the
book about how Donald Regan who became
the chief of staff in the second term
made a cardinal error which was in
finding her a pain in the neck and so he
at some point because she was always
interfering she took her husband's
business very seriously and his image
especially seriously
so Regan put put an aide in place
between himself and the first lady that
would deal with her supposedly he tried
to delegate Nancy to somebody else
she was taken having none of it and it
was not very long after that that Regan
found himself fired kicked out from
being chief of staff he learned about it
from the media nobody even told him
directly and Nancy Reagan as everybody
knew was behind it
so she played a gigantic role in in that
White House why did you not cover the
summit at Reykjavik so I could not cover
the summit at Reykjavik because even
though I did cover the White House back
in those bad old days there was a saying
that women don't do throw weight which
meant that women women reporters
couldn't quite understand all the
complications of nuclear warfare and it
was just too much for our our little
heads to be able to wrap around so when
I wanted to cover a Kovach like the guy
reporter
I was told no I'd have to stay home and
they'd be sending someone from the
Pentagon um the people that covered the
Pentagon one of the guys in the office
to cover Reykjavik I'd stay home and I
was told maybe while I was home I could
do a story about Nancy Reagan's favorite
dress designer kind of gives you a
glimpse into how the world has changed
back then you can even be the White
House reporter but still told you
couldn't manage to cover arms control
but dress designers were probably a
better subject for you so what was it
like to be a White House reporter you
know in many ways I mean I look back on
it and think I was so lucky to have been
able to see Reagan up close and to see
it to get to know I mean there was
wonderful access for The Wall Street
Journal during that period so I really
knew a lot of the people right around
Reagan but truthfully as a reporting job
it's it's one of the worst beats because
you don't really get to get beneath the
surface with anyone you're constantly
covering every burp every jot and jit
you're so busy all day long you never
get to really you know find out the real
stories and that's kind of why I wrote
the first book I again wanted to see
well how did this happen because we'd
missed one of the biggest stories in the
White House and which was the
iran-contra affair none of us knew it
was going on we were sitting there
covering everything every day with no
idea this incredible scandal had been
unfolding and it was actually the
Attorney General Edwin Meese who told
the press corps he came and it gave us a
briefing and it was like what oh you've
got to be kidding so at that point you
know you had to realize defeat we had
not really managed to catch the news in
the White House while we were covering
it
what was it theme of the book where'd
you get the title in the subtitle for
lands for the unmaking the president
well the idea of the book was that any
you can see I've just looked at it again
it been a couple years since I'd ever
looked at it really the story is how a
President's second-term unravels and
it's it's not unusual really
historically second terms are tough for
presidents and in this case Reagan
really had a kind of a vapid theme for
his second term it was morning in
America and he they didn't really get
public consensus for any of the things
he was trying to do because they didn't
run on issues for the second term so
it's about kind of how they went off
course in the second term two oh two
seven four eight eight two zero two if
you live in the eastern central time
zones two oh two seven four eight eight
two zero three for those of you in the
mountain and Pacific and if you want to
send a text message to zero to seven one
seven nine six eight for Jane Mayer's
our guests Clyde and Hamden Maine you
are first up today hi good afternoon I
bought the book it's a great book I'm
about a third of the way into it which
book like how dark money okay and really
appreciate to know we had matter and
knowledge a smattering of these details
but never comprehensive and in-depth
like this book does in the early pages
of the book she mentions that Justice
Thomas and Justice Scalia both addressed
the Koch brothers secret meetings that's
doing their bitter in the early stages
of trying to organize their conspiracy
does she I like to know if she has any
more information on that chamber thanks
for asking
you know I there have been a few more
stories about both and there has been
coverage of that that what happens he's
talking about the Koch brothers have
hold meetings twice a year with top
donors that they've gathered around them
there's sort of a group of about 400 to
500 of the richest conservatives in the
country get together behind closed doors
and they bring him bring in important
figures to talk to them and candidates
to talk to them who are sort of
auditioning for support from this
extraordinarily wealthy group and in
over the years among the the public
figures who have attended these secret
meetings
our two Supreme Court justices one
former Justice Scalia and current
Justice Thomas what transpired I mean
part of the reason I wrote this book was
because it's all been so secret it's
hard to even get lists in fact you can't
get lists of all the people who've gone
to these meetings the donor list slipped
out at one such meeting which gives us a
guest list but basically it's it's a
it's a closely held secret and the cokes
have gone out of their way to try to
keep the secret so they've even at some
points used these kind of white noise
makers that they surrounded the
perimeters of one such meeting with so
that the press couldn't eavesdrop or
hear anything there'd be kind of like
this kind of static sound so I wish I
could tell you more Clyde about exactly
what transpired when the Supreme Court
justices were there I think the public
should know this is obviously very
important business these are hugely
powerful people with tremendous
interests in front of the US government
great influence because of their wealth
and you've got people to two of the nine
justices meeting with them I think the
you know the public has a right to know
more about it but we don't really so but
I'm glad we know that they were there at
least jane mayer you also talked about
the Bradley Foundation and the Olin
Foundation in dark money who and what
are they so I'm glad you brought this up
because this book is partly about the
Koch brothers but it's really a history
of the founding families of the
conservative movement who works
they were the funding families too and
so the the the Olin Foundation has been
terrifically important in funding
academia in particularly trying to
balance what John M Olin who was the
founder of the Olin foundation felt was
a left-wing liberal tilt in academia and
he set out to try to use his fortune
from his company
to change that by having his Foundation
fund all kinds of educational programs
in colleges and particularly in law
schools there's something called the law
and economics movement which his
foundation funded which tries to make
judges and lawyers think about not just
what's just when they decide cases but
also whether it'll cost business a lot
of money and and take that into
consideration and they've been quite
quite successful in the law and
economics movement it's taught in many
many law schools that particularly were
aiming for the Ivy League's and they've
managed make a lot of headway into the
Ivy League law schools and to mint a
number of judges who very much support
this point of view now so John and
Mullen was an interesting man his
company was interesting he he liked the
cokes inherited the company from his
father it was a family privately owned
family company and what did they make
they made firearms and chemicals and it
became quite big and I was interested in
why he in particular became so
conservative and what sort of what why
he got engaged when he did in American
politics and what I discovered was that
his company produced a lot of chemicals
that were accused of creating terrible
pollution in the country they they they
created things that left towns polluted
with with mercury ponds and mercury
falling it going you know running into
streams one of the places where they had
a plant became the first toxic waste
site for a Superfund when it was created
so the whole in many ways you can see
the Olin foundation as a reaction
against the 1970s environmental movement
which created that that was the
beginning of the Environmental
Protection Agency there was Earth Day
there were all these guy it was a
bipartisan movement actually
environmentalism but the some of the
corporate
captain's in the country who were being
accused now of being huge polluters they
really took umbrage at it and john
emmalin was was somebody whose fortune
was made and was being accused of
polluting and took his fortune to try to
change the direction of the thinking of
the country in academia particularly and
fought in part the environmental
movement that was a big big part of the
cause so didn't he put in his will that
he wanted his money to run out when we
did and this is he he and there this is
also interesting some of these corporate
these hugely wealthy families had these
are the conservative funders were afraid
that their children might become
liberals because it's happened actually
it happened kind of with the Rockefeller
family and they're looking at this and
they're saying we do not want our
fortunes to fall into liberal hands even
in our own family so he made provisions
that his money would have to be spent
completely out and it you will see all
in chairs in universities and colleges
all over the country at this point still
so either he packed a punch with that
fortune and who are the Bradley's the
Bradley's were two brothers from
Milwaukee who made a fortune really in
in creating thermostat kind of things
rheostats and their fortune they wanted
to they were really quite civic minded
about Milwaukee and they were they were
very right-wing but they mostly were
interested in kind of improving life in
Milwaukee when they died though and they
that their fortune moved on their
foundation moved on into the hands of
other people who became super committed
to the conservative movement and those
funders in particular earmark that money
for the things we see now the Bradley
Foundation is a Leviathan among
right-wing foundations now and much of
the money came from defense contracts
ironically really because much of that
money in the Bradley Foundation is
earmarked for anti-government program
but so many millions of those dollars
came from the US government's defense
contracts this is an email from Ron lie
burger in Brookline Massachusetts Ms
Mayer I've long read your work in The
New Yorker and your books and completely
agree with your take on things are
taking larly since I grew up in Kansas
ah anyway what I want to ask you about
is your education at the Fieldston
School in New York
my late wife grew up in Manhattan and
went to Fieldston graduating in 1968 she
was a wonderful art critic and had a
great analytical insight and writing
style I wonder if you could reflect on
your own education of Fieldston and what
it provided you as a basis for your own
ethical analytical and writing abilities
my wife always said Brandeis was a piece
of cake after her education in fields
huh well thanks for asking and I'm sorry
about your wife but your Fieldston I
went there from the time I was four
until almost the end of my high school
education and then I went off to a
boarding school in England but Fieldston
taught ethics which made it unusual
among schools I guess some schools have
you know Chapel and or you know some
sort of religious orientation Fieldston
was an ethical culture school so what
that meant was we spent an hour every
week debating what's right and what's
wrong and looking at historic ethical
dilemmas and at the time I have to say
we didn't take it that seriously in
school you know we were kids and we
thought great this is one classic or
you're not going to get graded and you
can kind of horse around a little bit I
think in retrospect it maybe did have an
impact it certainly has made me very
interested in right and wrong and issues
about power and abuses of power which i
think is a theme that runs through all
the things that I've written so and they
did teach us to to write I guess you
know I still struggle with writing to
this day but but it certainly did a lot
of reading of great literature Bob is
calling in from Bradenton Florida Bob
your
book TV with Jane Mayer yes miss Mayer I
wanted to tell you that I completed your
book and I found it very very powerful
and congratulate you I just wish that we
could clone you and have more people
like you before us the I myself have
intertwined a little bit with the Koch
brothers I was born in Wichita I
interviewed with Fred Koch to go to MIT
and I attended school with Bill and Dave
two twins the thing I'm observing is
that as the all of these techniques that
the Koch brothers are put through to try
to control the situation had come into
play the populace especially the workers
have become more and more enraged and
under pressured due to these programs
being put in place through Alec and
other things and it appears that the
backlash of the workers is trumping all
of their efforts through Donald Trump at
least this moment and possibly also
through Bernie Sanders and I wanted to
get your opinion on what that is all
about so interesting well at some point
I'll have to catch up with you and hear
what they were all like it an MIT and
what the dad was like I think that Fred
Koch the father Fred Koch was a loomed
very very large in the lives of these
boys he was a huge figure and very tough
figure so I agree with the caller that
what we're looking at in the in in the
Trump phenomenon in some ways is
something of a Frankenstein that was
created partly by these huge donors the
huge right wing donors who as that the
piece in in the Harvard study says
pulled the Republican Party so far to
the right on economic issues they kind
of captured the party to serve the
interests of the big donors cutting
taxes on the top brackets cutting all
kinds of social
grams for people who are struggling and
they left out I think a lot of the
middle-class and working-class voters
and kind of the rank-and-file in their
own party and that the the you know if
you look at how the cokes have done on
the years during the during the Obama
administration they've done phenomenally
well and so have many of the other
people who were the top donors in the
country the super-rich have done
amazingly well in the recovery but
they've left a lot of people behind and
they and their policies would shred the
social safety net the coxa for instance
wanted to abolish social security since
it was started and they certainly wanted
they talked about privatizing it these
days and so I think you're right they
have left a lot of people behind there
with their policies and with their
pushing for these kind of minimal
government that doesn't do much for
anybody and I think that they've left a
lot of people really mad and some of
those people have gone to Bernie Sanders
and a lot of those people on the
Republican side have gone to Donald
Trump who interestingly is saying things
that are different from the donors
Republican orthodoxy about Social
Security for instance he's saying he's a
fan of Social Security and wants to
strengthen it
that's something middle-class voters
here he's talking saying he thinks that
Medicare and Medicaid are good ideas
they hear that too and he's also poked
fun at some of the big financiers who he
says don't really pay their taxes
because of things like the carried
interest tax loophole so he's playing
this populist thing where he is
he's saying you know I know these rich
guys and they get away with murder and I
think that you know a lot of the middle
class and the working class and
rank-and-file voters they hear that and
they agree with it so they're mad at the
party that these donors have created
here's a text message from Miami and a
reminder if you do send in a text
message if you could include your city
and your first name that would be great
but this is from Miami kind of ties in a
lot of your world's a lot of your topics
thoughts on citizens united will it be
overturned I guess the answer to whether
it will be overturned depends on
on the court I mean I think you know
this is a very key moment for a lot of
big legal issues and Citizens United
certainly one of them
Hillary Clinton has said she will try to
appoint someone who will overturn it
Bernie Sanders has said the same I don't
think that I know that Donald Trump has
said anything about it one way or the
other he of course claims to be
self-funding I don't know if that is an
improvement
to have to have billionaires running in
order to you know make it to the
presidency on their own you know steam
or if it's better to have billionaires
behind the scenes you know earmarking
donations for their favorite candidates
as if they're backing racehorses you
know either way it's it's a it's been as
far as I'm concerned a huge problem for
the country both Democrats and
Republicans and I think the lack of
transparency about the money because of
the amount of money that's dark money as
the name of this book is going through
groups that claim to be 501 C 4 s it's a
huge problem there's billions of
earliest millions and millions of
dollars of secret money sloshing through
American politics at this point and from
dark money Jane Mayer writes contrary to
predictions the Citizens United decision
hadn't triggered a tidal wave of
corporate political spending instead it
had empowered a few extraordinarily rich
individuals with extreme and often
self-serving agendas well that is true I
mean and what what I think everybody or
at least critics worried about of the
Citizens United decision was that it
would unleash corporate spending because
remember the corporations were sort of
granted free speech rights and so people
thought all businesses are going to pour
money into politics and overwhelm you
know the debates that's really not what
happened because for at least four
public corporations it's too
controversial they don't want to
alienate their customers by getting
heavily involved in partisan politics
and so we've seen companies like Target
back off instead what we've gotten our
enormous ly wealthy individuals and if
you think about it they
what kind of people want to spend that
much money in American politics most
normal people don't have views that they
care that much about so inevitably
you're going to get people with very
very intense views or people who have a
lot at stake people who've got
self-interest at stake
next call for jane mayer comes from joe
in Olympia Washington hi Joe hi thanks
for taking my call and this is a bit of
a change in directions but still keeping
with the same theme of the power of
money in our society and being an artist
I'm very interested in that role in
culture you wrote a wonderful article
that called musical gold The New Yorker
and it was looking at the carpenter
family and the price of very expensive
old Italian violins and I'd like to know
what drew you to that story how you got
appointed or you pick that story and
then what your takeaway was now that you
thought about it well I so wish I'd
written it it sounds really good
I I wonder if maybe it's possible that
it could have been written by my
colleague Jane Kramer sometimes we get
each other's compliments and I wish I
could take credit for her work that it
might have been a Jane Kramer story I do
come from a musical family I have to say
my dad's a composer and my brother's a
concert pianist but I've never written
about violence because I was kind of the
musical reject of the family you're also
a Lehman
as in Lehman Brothers aren't you by
descendent you know Mike I think they
were my great great great grandfather
and great great great uncle founded
Lehman Brothers the banking the
investment bank on one side of my family
there's a I'm that that side of the
family were you know from Germany
originally and they were the German Jews
and on the other side of my family I
come from Christians from Illinois who
had a hog farm and who the my
grandfather eventually became left the
farm and came to New York and became a
historian Alan Evans and ran the history
department at Columbia so I
like to think of my family is kind of a
melting pot we have a little bit of
everything and and it makes me you know
love the history of the country because
it's very varied in my family next call
for Jane Mayer comes from Richard and
Haverhill Massachusetts Richard you're
on book TV on c-span - yes thanks c-span
- Jane my wife in the middle of the book
and obviously I'll be reading it out -
what she loved it but Jane I wanted to
talk about the Koch brothers and what
they couldn't get done in Washington
they focus their attention and money and
resources we in the States we electing a
lot of Republican governors a lot of
state legislatures other Republicans
consequently the 31 Republican governors
and they've restricted the wrote that
their voting rights restricted women's
health care services they started the of
The Stand Your Ground laws the right to
work state laws there were big fans of
governor from Wisconsin and you know in
this year and in 2018 the governors that
take over in the state registers that
take over they're going to be
redistricting again for another ten
years so it's going to be pretty bad if
that happens and we get gerrymandering
all over again your your comments Jane
please well you're you're absolutely
right that and I think people often miss
this the people and the press spend so
much time looking at presidential
politics they don't really pay that much
attention to what's going on in the
states and and and even below the state
level and and what the cokes have been
really smart about with their operatives
who have sort of looked at American
politics like engineers and figured out
how do you engineer social change in
this country and they realize the states
were key among other things money goes
so much further at that level at the
presidential level it's very hard to
have money completely by you what you
want but if you pour money into
a race where there's not much press
coverage so voters don't know much about
it one way or the other you can frame
the issues much better and you can have
a much bigger impact and so the cokes
specifically and the conservative
movement specifically set their sights
on states going back to the 80s and you
were talking about Alec
that's the American Legislative Exchange
Council it's an organization that the
cokes have funded in fact Charles Koch
helped bail it out when it was in
financial trouble early on
they've been very important to it and
they've focused specifically on state
legislators which are you know most
people don't pay much attention to
really but they're very important
especially to businesses in the and so
they poured money into them and in in
terms of gerrymandering I tell the story
in my book about how in in 2009 when
Obama was was so he was popular still
the Conservatives were kind of a twits
and at what they could do and one very
smart guy ed gillespie who had been the
the chairman of the Republican community
said I know what we should do focus on
the states so in 2010 which was going to
be a redistricting year they had
something called red map and it was a
kind of a secretive project where they
aimed to serve target legislators with
money and flip them from Democratic to
Republican control and see if they
wanted to get as many as they could
because the following year those
legislators would redistricting Gresham
districts and they did fantastically
well they picked up I think was 537
legislative seats that that year for the
Republicans and they you're overwhelmed
the House of Representatives of course
people remember that there was a
Republican tide that took over the house
and they redistricted and the amazing
thing about the redistricting that took
place that gerrymandering was in 2012 in
total America cast more votes for
Democrats than Republicans but more
Republicans were represented
were elected to the House of
Representatives so that the districts
were so expertly gerrymandered that even
though a majority voted for Democrats
more Republicans were took their seats
so monomeric job it was very skilled
very deliberate there was a lot of
secret money that went into it and it
was smart and I think the thing about
the cokes you have to remember is they
are engineers and they work with people
who have very sort of precise ideas
about how to affect change they're not
mushy thinkers they're not sort of you
know that they are very precise and if
something doesn't work they go back to
the drawing board and figure out what
went wrong and try it again in a
different way and they did a great job
in 2010 of grabbing those legislative
seats and working state politics and
it's a big frontier for them now again
how do you do you get a pick what topics
you cover in The New Yorker to some
extent I mean sometimes someone has a
great idea which I welcome if some of
the editors have a good idea because I
you know I I run out of them some time
but often one story leads to another I
mean the cokes writing about the cokes
was my idea and in part it was just
again serendipity I was turning a corner
in Manhattan and I looked up at Lincoln
Center I grew up in New York and there
was David Koch's name and I had I knew a
little bit about the cokes The Times
magazine had done a story about the
cokes ten years earlier and I remembered
it and and I knew they were putting a
little money into the Tea Party at that
point which looked like a mass uprising
and as I grounded that corner and looked
at David Koch's name I thought if
anybody in Manhattan has any idea who
these these these brothers are because I
think there's a story there and so I
started digging and at that point the
cokes were busy saying and there they
rather having their spokesmen were
saying they had nothing to do with the
Tea Party they weren't funding it they'd
they this wasn't they weren't behind it
but and they weren't giving me an
interview so I just flew to one of the
meetings they were having
sort of a big weekend rally and it was
filled with tea party people who the
cokes organization Americans for
Prosperity was were training they were
giving training sessions to the tea
party they were giving awards out to tea
party members and so the cokes own
political organization was deeply
embedded in trying to organize the tea
party and when I asked the woman who was
in charge there she was it was in Texas
her name was Peggy Venable I said you
know so you guys supporting the tea
party and she said oh yeah
you know we were into the tea party
before it was cool and gave me this
whole interview about how interrelated
the two things were it was clear that a
lot of the money going into the Tea
Party that was helping organize it and
turn the opposition into a movement
against Obama was coming from super
wealthy donors like the cokes very
effective movement though it was very
effective it was it was um I think
partly because the Obama White House was
so ineffective I mean they were taken by
surprise they they you remember Obama
was elected with this idea that there's
no rat America no blue America we're all
just one United States of America which
is a really nice idea but he won he
didn't really sense or notice the right
wing as it was organizing against him
and I don't think he knew much about the
big money that was coming after him he
hadn't tangled with it much before in
his career and it was organizing as soon
as he was elected and they'd I mean they
had a meeting the week right after he
was inaugurated the the coke donors got
together to figure out how they could
kind of fight back Cynthia's in
Carpinteria California good afternoon
Cynthia good afternoon you thank you for
taking my call I'm very interested I
haven't read your book that sounds like
it's very thorough and everything well
I'm wondering is have you investigated
anything about the Clinton Foundation
and all of their money and what they are
doing with that and because we hear a
lot about you know other countries
donating to her and influencing
no politics internally in our country
through their foundation so there's
money on both sides you know I'm not
naive enough to know I mean to think
that only the Conservatives have big
money you know supporting them have you
done any investigation and that was
Cynthia in California and Dorothy has a
text message very similar do you know
about the dark money the Clintons
collected incidents like the United Bank
of Switzerland donating 23 million to
them after Hillary got the IRS to drop
an effort to get the names of 55
billionaires hiding their money hmm I
don't know about that but I do know I
mean I have written about when Clinton
was president of course there were all
kinds of financial shenanigans that took
place and so when he was president I was
still a reporter at the at the New
Yorker and wrote about the kind of
remember there was a revolving door
practically with the the Lincoln Bedroom
there where the big donors were coming
in and there was a scandal involving a
Chinese donor johnny chung was his name
who described the White House as being
like a turnstile where you know where
you buy a subway token and when you put
in the money you get to you know you get
to come in and get what you want I mean
it was it was a you know a pretty see me
sounding picture so I have been you know
on book leave working on this book for
the last five years so I haven't had a
chance yet to really dig into the
Clinton Foundation but I think it's
certainly fair game to take a really
close look at it and I think all
foundations to in my mind should be much
more carefully policed by the IRS to
make sure that when we as citizens give
them tax breaks for putting money into
them they are all supposed to be doing
things that are in the public interest
not things that are just in their
private interests not just pushing their
corporate interests or their political
interests they're supposed to be in the
public interest and I really would like
to see much better policing of
foundations because there's something
like 800 billion dollars right now in
American foundations that's a huge pot
of money and it packs a punch in our
public
realm in terms of public policy so I
mean I I certainly agree with the caller
that no single party has you know all
the angels on its side and that all of
this is a area that reporters need to
look at very very closely how'd you get
to The New Yorker I got to The New
Yorker after writing the book about
Clarence Thomas actually I was working
on the book about Clarence Thomas and
someone of The New Yorker asked me to
review a book called the real Anita Hill
by David Brock and it was a book that
said that Anita Hill was a fantasy stand
had made all of this up and at first I
remember thinking I shouldn't review a
rival book I sort of had a conflict of
interest and it it didn't seem like the
right thing to do so I just said let's
wait and see and anyway while we were
waiting and seeing this book the real
Anita Hill began to be taken seriously
as if it was true and I knew from the
reporting I'd been doing that it wasn't
true that it was filled with lies and I
began to feel oh gosh I've got like some
responsibilities now I'm probably one of
the only people who really truly does
know that this book is full of lies
because I had done so much reporting
myself I thought okay I got a
responsibility to just get the truth out
there so I reviewed the book in The New
Yorker along with Jill Abramson it was
just as I was about having our my my
baby daughter
I remember fact-checking while I was in
the hospital with a New Yorker
delivering and the review came out and I
think we did the right thing
it it it kind of shone a light on some
really twisted things in that book by
David Brock and many years later it's
such a strange story many years later
David Brock changed his point of view
completely he admitted that his book was
wrong about Anita Hill he apologised it
need a hill he apologized to myself and
to Jill Abramson personally and he has
now become kind of the leading I don't
know how to describe you Larry the kind
of a pro-hillary operative on the
Democratic side he's gone from being a
leading conservative operative to a
leading liberal operative so it's a very
strange story but I've got to say it
least bears out the fact that Jill and I
were right he admits it himself that's
that book was not right and and and he
is now saying so so that's how I got to
the New Yorker with that review it
stirred up a lot of interest and soon
after that The New Yorker said would you
consider writing for us I was on
maternity leave from The Wall Street
Journal and I thought great well first
of all the New Yorker is the most
amazing publication in the country so I
jumped at that and also it seemed like a
way I could be a mom and write at the
same time Tina Brown was header Tina
Brown was the editor and I thought I'd
have a little more control over my
schedule so I could it both be home with
my baby some of the time and write these
stories for the best publication I knew
so I was lucky what was it like to work
for Tina Brown
she was great actually Tina Brown is
she's a genius
I think when it comes to the subject of
pairing writers with subjects and we
would sit in these meetings and she was
like a like a you know a producer on on
in Hollywood and she say we must have
so-and-so write about that and and she
was right the combination would be just
completely combustible and so she was
really fun to work with I I enjoyed
working with Tina a lot she was a
taskmaster too though I mean we get
faxes at 3:00 in the morning from her
and you know so you jumped
I mean she's demanding appreciative
creative fun I really enjoyed working
with her Howard's in Saint Cloud Florida
Howard thanks for holding you're on with
author Jane Mayer thank you for for
having me
in your in your book you talk a lot
about the the funding by the cokes
of universities and I made me think of
the Chris Hedges book on the death of
the liberal class and he excoriated
liberals who may have been victims of
cokes nefarious work in the university
system did anybody ever discuss that he
ever discussed this with you did anybody
ever bring this to your attention no I
actually don't know um the book by Chris
Hedges that you're talking about I
certainly know who Chris Hedges is but I
haven't read that but there's you know I
mean what-what I write about is really
in some ways the frontier of what the
cokes are funding right now you think a
lot about them putting all this money
into presidential and other races this
year and that money 889 million is huge
but what they're doing so much more
deliberately and systematically is
funding programs in colleges and
universities to try to recruit young
people to having their point of view
they've met their I think the Koch
Foundation's are currently funding
programs in something like three hundred
and seven different schools colleges and
universities and they're more I mean
pretty much every month I see a Google
Alert on another school that they're
beginning to pour money into and it's
what I write about in my book is that
they have had their eye on young people
from the start almost I have a paper
that I discovered that it's actually
part of a secret history that was
written of the Koch brothers by someone
who knew the family his name is Clayton
Kaufman and what he describes is Charles
Koch very early on wrote about how we
need to start a radical movement and
that youth were the best way to do it
you need to recruit kids because they're
opened new ideas and he aimed for the
youth and they somebody he was working
with at that time Leonard Leo another
libertarian very radical libertarian at
that point said we should
copy that Nazi youth movement literally
he's writing about this saying you know
the Nazi youth movement he's not saying
we should become Nazis but he's saying
they created a sense of identity by
getting very young people into a
movement where they identified as
particular ideology so this was very
much the plan that was 1976 when those
papers were being written and this is
kind of the fulfillment of it these days
you can see in so many schools the cokes
are funding one after the next after the
next they're you know trying to sort of
plant their programs in various
economics departments mostly Gerry
Phoenix good morning good afternoon good
morning morning thank you for taking my
call I'm not quite through the book but
I have looked up out of personal
interest 20 references to the John Birch
Society and it might be of real interest
that that I debated as a spokesman of
the John Birch Society
congressman Russo at Arizona State
University
Tyler Hall at the time the John Birch
Society was swinging mightily in Arizona
and the right-wing newspaper
well after after that debate and I
quoted of course where Welch in his blue
book called Eisenhower as a tool of the
Communists or a communist and so forth
well I then went to a debate where
Rehnquist who is then a lawyer in
Phoenix
debated another lawyer in Phoenix about
a civil rights issue at the lawyers Club
and Rehnquist quoted at length from
Robert Welch that month's issue of
American opinion American opinion was
the semi-monthly publication of Robert
Welch and I thought you might find it
interesting that in Phoenix it was
generally known to those of us who were
knowledgeable that broke Brophy prep and
all of that power in Arizona was tied
into the John Birch Society and
the Arizona Republic which controlled
the state excoriated me in their
editorial count for my criticism of the
John Birch Society a true patriotic
thing so I I don't know if anybody's
ever checked to find if in fact
Rehnquist was a member of the JPS but
it's that debate was taken entirely from
that month's American opinion and
Rehnquist when I called that would not
disavow it he just said he didn't want
to talk so I thought you might find that
interesting
it's Jerry in Phoenix Arizona and it's
interesting I I just don't know I would
assume when when Rehnquist was being
confirmed that people must have looked
at his ties to the John Birch Society so
I you know I
that's interesting the cokes were in
fact both Charles and David were members
in the John Birch Society as was their
father Fred was one of the founding
members their father so again what I
found so interesting is that again we
all think of the John Birch Society as a
kind of a fringe group I mean how you
know it people who belong to it thought
as the caller said that Eisenhower was a
secret communist plant and you know it's
that's far-fetched face it but just the
same
they felt that worldview that seems so
kind of laughable in some ways is has
generated these brothers that are so
powerful now in the Republican Party and
I think the story the history that I've
been trying to tell is how did those
views become so mainstreamed into
American politics and and and part of
the answer is that there was so much
money poured in to mainstreaming them
through so many organizations that most
Americans didn't realize we're funded by
one tiny group of people they just kept
pouring money in and the organizations
that didn't look connected kept
militating for these ideas and
eventually you know the ideas got more
currency and now they're really very
much accepted in many places I mean you
hear today many of the Republican
candidates for the presidency are
talking about abolishing the IRS now I
mean it sounds like a kind of a
ludicrous position you who's going to
collect the taxes then we may not like
the IRS but somebody's got to do it but
that's a position that the libertarian
party took in 1980 when David Koch ran
as vice president and it was considered
laughable then today it's being
mainstreamed by the Republican
candidates you know it's moved far the
center of gravity on the Republican side
of politics has moved so far to the
right during the period that I've been
covering politics that people sort of
forget about it but it's not really that
long a time and part of the reason is
because of very determined very smart
and very rich donors does the John Birch
Society still exist today I I think some
form of it has been reincarnated it's
not a major factor but I suppose what's
more important is a lot of its ideas
seem to be burbling up again every month
wouldn't we have an author on we asked
him or her about their influences about
the books they're reading etc etc well
we asked Jane Mayer that information too
and here's a look at what she said
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when I tuned into it on the weekends
usually as authors sharing up their new
releases watching the nonfiction authors
on book TV is the best television for
serious readers on c-span they can have
a longer conversation and delve into
their subject book TV weekends they
bring you author after author after
author that spotlight the work of
fascinating people
I love book TV and I'm a c-span fans
[Music]
Jane Mayer Charlotte's Web Charlotte's
Web oh well I discovered also when I
read it to my own daughter it's
beautifully written it is so gorgeous
EB white is such a hero in the beautiful
use of the English language and um you
know it's just the most moving story
what can you say it's about life death
regeneration love and pigs wilbur 202 is
the area code if you would like to talk
with author and new yorker staff writer
jane mayer seven four eight eight two
zero two for those of you in the east
and central time zone seven four eight
eight two zero three if you live in the
mountain in pacific time zones we've got
a little over an hour left in our
program today on book TV you can also
contact via social media book TV at
c-span org is our email address at book
TV if you'd like to leave a Twitter
message and you can make a comment on
our Facebook page facebook.com slash
book TV and you can send a text not a
phone call but a text to 202 seven one
seven nine six eight four just text only
and if you would include your first name
and your city that would be great jane
mayer is the author of four books
beginning in 1988 with landslides the
unmaking of the president strains
justice came out in 1994 co-authored
with the former New York Times editor
Jill Abramson the dark side the inside
story of how the war on terror turned
into a war on American ideals came out
in 2008 and finally dark money just came
out this year jane mayer you wrote
darkside in 2008 the bush administration
was still in office it's 2016 Guantanamo
still open it's so I think not what many
people thought would happen but I
definitely want to get to that but
before leaving Charlotte's Web behind I
just want to say one other thing I was
just thinking about you know why why
does a book
you know resonate and stick with us from
childhood on and you know I think one of
the things about Charlotte's Web is it's
the story of the runt
Wilbur who was the piglet that was going
to die probably because he was the runt
of the litter
and you know there's something about
rooting for the underdog
that I think is so appealing to most
Americans this idea that you know that
that you you could start as the runt of
the litter but you you have talent and
in the end you know he he does really
well through sort of dint of you know
trying really hard and and he's saved by
a little girl who doesn't want to you
know have the farmer just kill him off
because he's the runt and these are just
I think in some ways it's just such an
American story that and that it
resonates so much with so many kids so
anyway they're all so beautiful
illustrations and in the beginning I
wanted to be an illustrator not a writer
and I wanted in fact - I wanted to
either illustrate children's books or be
a cartoonist and the first things I
submitted to the New Yorker were
cartoons not not stories did he ever get
published no I got very nice rejection
notes I did get a cartoon published in
The Wall Street Journal when I worked
there and I had cartoons published in
the Rutland Herald when I worked there
and at Yale when I was in college and
it's really what I wanted to do but it's
very hard to make a living being a
cartoonist so anyway for all those
reasons I I'm you know much of my heart
is I love children's literature so I was
loved having a kid where I could read
these stories that out loud and enjoy
the illustrations all over again but
going to slightly darker subjects of the
subject of Guantanamo I you know I think
it's just a pity that this country seems
to be kind of gradually acclimating to
the idea that we would have people held
in detention without trials indefinitely
I mean there we
we have the right to a speedy trial we
have a fantastic justice system we have
a justice system that has heard trials
of terrorists and put them away for life
but some of the most dangerous
terrorists involved in sort of the 9/11
era situation and why you know it's only
politics as far as I can tell that has
gotten in the way of us doing the right
thing here which is putting these
terrorists who are down in Guantanamo on
trial and give them a military trial if
you want but they really should put them
in article 3 courts where the
prosecutors are itching to prosecute
them the US Attorney's Office in New
York has such good cases against many of
these guys down in Guantanamo and it's
Congress that's standing in the way and
acting as if for some reason these
terrorists are too good or too powerful
to be tried in our own courts and I
think that's hooey and I think it's a
real pity but as the Obama
administration continued the same
policies that the Bush administration
had in many ways they have I mean
they've you know they've they tried in
the beginning I mean as you might
remember I think that the first week
Obama was president he said he was going
to aim to close down Guantanamo and
they've argued that their hands have
been tied by Congress but they've
they've participated in some of the same
policies I mean for instance early on
there were going to be some some of the
detainees down there were weekers there
sort of Chinese Muslims they're not
terrorists according to the Bush
administration they were not terrorists
and the US was about to take one or two
of them to show its good faith that we
too could could rehabilitate some of
these people and when word got out about
it
the Obama White House freaked out just
as much as the Republicans were freaking
out they were afraid that it was going
to look bad politically something bad
would happen and so they they would they
welched on a deal to take some of the
weaker Zinn to America instead they were
sent to Bermuda of Wall
where they're busy working and I think
it's at least one and maybe two people
working at a country club taking care of
the sand traps and things like that
nothing terrible's happened with the
wiggers in Bermuda we could have done
this in this country and demonstrated
that we too can take some of these
people instead of treating them like
lepers that are too dangerous to have in
your country III think it's it's it's
pitiful really Bob is calling in from
Overland Park Kansas Bob you're on with
author Jane Mayer greetings from the
state of Kansas which has been described
as a division of Koch Industries I'm
really interested in you know the last
chapter you talk about the rebranding of
the cokes and and you you cite Jamie all
'its and professor at wake forest who
described the power of reframing and the
movement towards promoting well-being as
a way of injecting a new face on
free-market capitalism
I'm interested in your elaboration on
that because I really see that it's
really being the next major influence
and how that I think is being cropped up
you mentioned that it's appearing at
universities throughout the country so
I'm interested in more about that well
thanks for asking and hide to Kansas and
you know that it's I write about it in
this this last chapter of the book is
based partly on a leaked tape that came
out from one of the secret meetings that
the cokes had with their donors and in
that meeting there's some fascinating
material where Richard Fink who has been
one of their political lieutenants for
many many years
talks about kind of us a problem that
they agreed that they had after 2012
2012 the election was a big
disappointment for the cokes they had
helped in their donor group or money
behind Romney and were hoping that they
could stop Obama from getting
and obviously they failed so afterwards
they did a ton of internal market
research according to Richard Fink their
aide who's talking to the donors in the
state he describes how they did all of
these focus groups and looked at
something like a hundred and seventy
thousand polls and he describes how they
realized they had an image problem the
country regarded them that is very
right-wing libertarian corporate donors
as greedy and they needed to appear to
have good intent if they were going to
convince the country to come their way
politically they talk about how the
country's divided in three parts
one-third of the country is left-wing or
liberal and will never accept the cokes
message another third is conservative or
right-wing and is already with them as
they describe it but that middle third
is what they're aiming at if they want
to win over the country and get their
policies implemented they need to win
over that middle third and that's what
they're aiming for and so they they did
all this research kind of market
research really which is not unusual for
a huge corporation to figure out how do
you sell the coke brand not just the
brand of coke industries but of the coke
politics how do you how do you market it
better and they came to the conclusion
that if they needed to show good intent
among the things they should do is
describe their movement as a movement
for well-being that free markets make
people happy free markets supposedly
give people opportunity if you shrink
the government from the way they
describe it you will bring well-being to
America and so from that point on they
started a well-being Institute and they
started talking about well-being in many
of their programs and so you can hear
that word it pops up again and again
they also came to the conclusion that
people regarded them as highly partisan
very right-wing due to the fact that
they actually occupied the
this right-wing of the country on the
spectrum and so in order to seem more
open-minded they talked about how they
needed to form alliances with unexpected
allies and among those allies they
introduced during that secret summit
were the National Association of
criminal defense lawyers and the United
Negro College Fund and they announced
that they were going to be giving more
money they've given money in the past to
these groups they're gonna get a lot
more money to these groups and make a
push for working with Democrats on some
issues like criminal justice reform they
also poured money for the first time
into corporate advertising for Koch
Industries which many of us see I've
seen it at baseball games you've seen it
on TV probably on Sunday mornings you've
seen it all over the place and where
they kind of have the kind of
traditional soft focus ads the show a
baby and you know a Huggies or something
and describe how you know they they are
creating a better future for America
so they've the pouring money into a new
image and you will see we call it the
New Coke you'll see it out there
everywhere but actually is it a new coke
it's the same philosophy politically and
it's just being sold in a new way well
Jane Mary you quoted Charles coke or
David coke is saying though the whale
that gets harpooned is the one who
spouts but here are two recent media
appearances by the Koch brothers
some days it seems like all David Koch
does is give give give
he gave Lincoln Center 100 million
dollars to help support the ballet he
gave a hundred and eighty five million
to MIT 20 million to the American Museum
of Natural History an entire wing to New
York Presbyterian Hospital and 65
million dollars for thousands at the
Metropolitan Museum of Art who are not
well liked primarily because of your
very conservative politics describe your
political point of view well I'm
basically a libertarian and I'm a
conservative on economic matters and I'm
a social liberal you support gay rights
you support a woman's right to choose
but conservative candidate you support
and many of them do not have those views
well that's their problem I'm I do have
those views what I want these candidates
to do is to support a balanced budget
and I'm very worried that if the budget
is not balanced that inflation could
occur and the economy of our country
could suffer terribly so the candidates
you support are because of their fiscal
policies most important that's exactly
right so Barbara I am really focused
intensely on economic and fiscal issues
because if those go bad the country as a
whole suffers terribly
do you think it's good for the political
system that so much what's called dark
money is flowing into the process now
well first of all my what I give isn't
dark like what I give to politically
that that's all reported it's either two
packs or to the candidates and what I
give to my foundations is is is all
public information but a lot of our
donors don't want to take the kind of
abuse that that I do they don't want
these attacks they don't want the death
threats
so they aren't going to participate if
they have to have their names associated
with it but you don't really consider
yourself a Republican not at all
no I consider myself a classical liberal
the way I like at it the Democrats are
taking us at about a hundred miles an
hour over the financial cliff and and
towards this two-tiered society the
Republicans are taking us there at
seventy miles an hour lesser of two
evils well I don't like to put it that
way
I would say yeah less unproductive where
do you think about that well it has been
so interesting to watch the the the
whales that didn't want to be harpooned
are now swimming around where you can
see them these days and it's such a
change from when I started writing about
the cokes I mean they were just it was
just five years ago they were the most
secretive billionaires in the country
and that was saying something but this
is part of the new public relations
effort that they are following they're
out there trying to talk and put a human
face on their views and I think it's you
know it's a smart policy probably I
think that they have certainly gotten a
lot of great publicity from Barbara
Walters you couldn't hardly buy
publicity like that about give give give
and you know it's it's interesting but
in that interview if you listen
carefully what you hear is that david
koch is saying i'm a libertarian don't
hate me I'm really good on he's saying
to sort of liberal New Yorkers where
he's a big player
go down k rights and I'm fine with
abortion but she says well then why
don't you you know you but you're giving
money to all these candidates who are
against them what you hear from that is
very true the cokes made more regardless
of their libertarian views on social
issues where they put their money which
is what matters where they put their
money is behind far-right candidates
that push all kinds of anti-gay right
and anti-abortion issues it's not
important to them what's important to
them is the economic issues the fiscal
issues they want fewer taxes and fewer
regulations fewer taxes on people like
themselves and fewer regulations on
businesses like theirs that's where
they're putting their money and that's
the movement that they are fueling and
the rest of them thinks it's just not
that important to them when where the
other at least if you're judging by
where they put their money so and so
when Charles says Charles Koch says also
in that CBS interview he doesn't like he
you know people sure saying WOW he says
he doesn't like the Republican Party so
he's not really a Republican doesn't
like either party so he kind of sounds
like somebody who's kind of not really
that engaged in politics he just doesn't
like politicians it's really actually
the same positions he's had since 1980
when he and his brother had his brother
run on the libertarian ticket they don't
like the Republican Party their way to
the right of the Republican Party
they've been trying to push it to the
right all these years they're not
pouring money into it and its candidates
but not because they like where it is
it's because they're trying to pull it
their way to have even lower taxes
smaller government fewer regulations
that's where they they want they want
this government to be way far right of
where it is now from Jane Mayer's dark
money while Obama's health care bill was
useful in riling up tea party protesters
his environmental and energy policies
were the real target of the
there's in billionaires in the Koch
circle if you had five minutes
with Charles Koch what would you ask him
you know um I think I I it's hard to
know I'm very interested in how he got
these views they really are unusually
radical and I'd like to talk to him
about his radicalism and what his vision
really is for this country because his
you know he talks about a lot of things
like corporate cronyism which sound like
something everybody can agree is not a
good thing but what is the libertarian
vision for America what does America
look like when it has almost no
government where is an example in the
world where there's a place with almost
no government that's a happy place the
places I think of with no government or
places like failed States they don't
look like happy places so I kind of
would like to know what where is he
trying to take this country mark in
Minneapolis thanks for holding you're on
with author Jane Mayer on book TV hi and
thanks for taking my call and thank you
to C stands for putting great authors
like this mayor on there's an air of the
book is marvelous it's courageous as was
the dark side and I have to confess that
can't read too much of the sitting
without getting up and going for some
extra blood pressure medicine it's so
it's daunting both the scope of the book
and discuss their influence so of the
many things I'd like to ask you for an
antidote for something this large it I
hate to use a cliche phrase but it seems
like it's metastasized is is being
Donald Trump the only way to overtly
fight this and and even then he's not
exposing it he's just raising a ruckus
against there that I'm a little lost and
and I don't want to be hopeless in all
this
and thank you again for just the
marvelous work that's mark and mini
Apple thank you so much for those kind
words you know I'm a reporter not a
politician so I'm not necessarily the
person that to turn to for the aunt
doats to everything but my personal
reason for doing this kind of work is I
do believe that the beginning of
reforming things that are wrong is
knowledge you have to know what's going
on so the very beginning for me is
reporting about it getting the
information out trying to get
transparency trying to let voters and
citizens in the country understand why
when Congress seems to do nothing
it won't deal with through common sense
issues why is that well you've got to
understand it's hands are tied by
private interests that it's serving and
you need to be able to see who those
interests are so I I think knowledge is
the beginning I think activism people
just getting involved in voting is
really truly important I think both
Trump and Bernie Sanders have shown
there's actually a very big population
in the country that's unhappy with what
they perceived to be political
corruption right now and this it's not
an issue that really had been addressed
that much before this campaign but the
amount of anger surrounding it on both
in both parties is fascinating it
suggests it's a very live topic out
there which means that it's a live area
where you could see reform because
obviously an awful lot of people are
upset about it Jane Mayer we talked
about this earlier but Eliot emails in
she attacks but Koch brothers what about
George Soros supporting Obama and
Hillary and you know Soros did I think
just put in some money to Hillary
Clinton's are the the supposedly
independent PAC that supports Hillary
Clinton none of these none of these
super PACs are truly independent of
their candidates as far as I'm concerned
though legally they are so it's
interesting it seems Soros is beginning
to put some serious money back into
politics and I I think that you know the
the idea that our political system
would be so influenced by such a small
group of people with that much money is
disturbing on both sides of the the
partisan divide III really think most
Americans just object the idea that 400
or 500 of the richest people in this
country will be picking their next
leader for them whether you're a
Democrat you're a Republican you're in
the middle I mean whatever it's just not
really the same as the idea of one-man
one-vote so I mean I think there's a lot
to worry about in both directions the
reason I have focused though and I have
to say this Ben even though it's going
to create controversy all over again
the reason I have focused on the cokes
in particular and on the Republican
right wing money in this book is that
when it comes to dark money in the last
election 80% of the undisclosed money in
2014 was on the right and that is where
the money is and if you're a political
reporter you follow the money and if
you're following the money you were
gonna hit the Koch brothers in this
country at this point The New Yorker
December 18th 28th 2014 by Jane Mayer
the unidentified queen of torture who
are we talking about well I did not
identify her there's somebody at the CIA
who is an officer who claims to be
undercover and who the agency says is
undercover who in many ways has had her
fingerprints all over among the most
egregious cases of what I regard is
torture having to do with the the
anti-terrorism program and we are not
allowed to identify her because the CIA
says she's undercover but it's it's it's
a long story I tell it in the dark side
of how the CIA in many ways people have
to realize missed missed the threat of
al Qaeda right before 9/11 I hate to
sound like Donald Trump or some of the
left-wing conspiracy theorists but I've
spent a lot of time trying to figure out
what the story really is and there were
many warnings that something terrible
was going to happen to the United States
and they were coming from some members
of the CIA the
house was not jumping as it probably
should have at those warnings and there
were also warnings that the CIA leads
that they dropped their that CIA
specifically had some information that
some of the people who later became
those hijackers on 9/11 were in the
United States and the CIA did not alert
the FBI to the presence of two of those
people who became those hijackers so
there were a lot of things that were
fumbled before 9/11 its human it happens
but there were reasons why people in the
CIA felt bad they they it was an
intelligence failure faced at 9/11 was
and so after 9/11 some of the same
people who had felt they dropped the
ball overcompensated and they did
everything they could to try to make
sure that they were not blindsided again
and part of what happened in that
overcompensation was that they used
methods that were I think in some ways
unconscionable and what's interesting
the unidentified queen of torture in the
story you're talking about was involved
both in dropping the ball and in
overcompensating afterwards so there are
the same characters who run through this
story on but before 9/11 and after and
she is one person in particular who has
been singled out for her role in this
behind the scenes but we at The New
Yorker did not decide to identify her
because she was undercover and we don't
do that is she still there
she is still there and she's in a major
role she and what's interesting is a
number of the people who did drop the
ball before 9/11 at the CIA have been
promoted since and are still involved
and you know again maybe this is just
human nature people are not perfect but
there was never a completely open kind
of investigation of all of this there's
they're never after after Pearl Harbor
was bombed there were public hearings
that were integrate the
and there were corrections made right
away there was not that kind of hearing
that took place publicly there were in
the 911 hearings but they didn't get
into the details of who dropped the ball
at the CIA and these names have never
come out October 1983 where were you I
will never forget and where I was that
morning was in Beirut I was a young
reporter for The Wall Street Journal I
was filling in for a more seasoned
reporter and I was rocked out of bed by
the sound of two huge explosions one of
which was our own Marine Barracks being
blown up by a terrorist and I jumped out
of bed got there as fast as I could
follow it around a reporter who knew
more about what he was doing than I did
and that was Tom Friedman of the New
York Times who was a spectacular
reporter and tried my best to cover what
was the first certainly glimpse I ever
got of you know radical Islamic
terrorism it was a horror to see it
sticks with me every October 23rd I
think of what I saw the Marine Barracks
was flattened like a pancake and with
layers of people in between the floors
that had fallen down and when I got
there you could still hear voices
screaming from inside of it begging to
be dug out but a lot of them just died
so I think it's over 240 250 young guys
died in that explosion and you know it
was it was a wake-up call for this
country I think about Islamic terrorism
but when I look back at it now I think
how interesting it is that Hillary
Clinton gets so much grief over Benghazi
we had so much trouble during that
period in Beirut with the Marine
Barracks being blown up and with the CIA
headquarters being blown up I mean there
were we had a great loss of American
life in in 11
during that period and and somehow
Ronald Reagan and his Teflon was never
really blamed for it but Hillary Clinton
that apparently doesn't have that Teflon
there was nothing like the loss of life
that she went through in Benghazi but it
sticks to her and sticks to her November
1989 November 1989 is also a night I
will never forget I was in Berlin again
for The Wall Street Journal I began to
feel a little bit like Calamity Jane I
had the luck of being sent over to
Germany to cover what seemed strange
which were some demonstrations in East
Germany that suggested maybe the Iron
Curtain was beginning to shimmer a
little in some strange way and so I went
over there to see what was going on in a
few days later the Berlin Wall opened
and that's what I was actually standing
there when it when the first people came
through I'd been having dinner with a
German family I don't speak German they
were listening to the radio they said oh
my god they're opening checkpoint
charlie so we drove over there and we
thought I must be wrong because nothing
was happening and as we were standing
there the people started to pour through
so it was the most unbelievable sight
for someone who's interested in history
and soon the Germans were just dancing
in the streets popping champagne singing
Deutschland uber alles and I was
dictating live to the front page of The
Wall Street Journal so and the next day
all the serious reporters who really
knew a lot about foreign affairs came in
but I you know I felt really good that
as a general assignment reporter the
foreign editor at The New Yorker and I
had had the luck or foresight or
whatever I give it to the foreign editor
to get there a few days early at the
Wall Street Journal I'm sorry at the
Wall Street Journal yeah could be
to be there in time yeah so fill in
orange Massachusetts thanks for holding
you're on with author Jane Mayer hi Jane
thanks for taking my call and thanks for
all the great work thank you so Donald
Trump just said that he would break up
dep by which of course he meant
say EPA and I'm wondering if you feel
that the Democratic presidential
candidate should try his or her best to
associate the Republican candidate
whether it's Trump or somebody else with
the environmental crimes of Koch
Industries and the Koch brothers
relentless assault against environmental
regulations that's my question well
thanks I think it's very interesting
question because people think of Trump
as being not a coke candidate the cokes
have obviously said they dislike him
behind the scenes he's not reliable in
terms of their point of view but he does
share a lot of their positions including
about global warming and about
environmental matters and those
positions are incredibly important to
coke industries kokis industries has a
terrible record on environmental
pollution it's had some of the biggest
judgments of any company in terms of
pollution judgments against it and it's
the largest creator of toxic waste in
the country or it was recently according
to EPA statistics and so III it's not
really up to me to tell the Democrats
how to run their campaigns but I think
it to me as a reporter it's something
worth pointing out that Donald Trump is
carrying the water of the fossil fuel
industry when he takes these positions
and of other polluters and you know
something I don't think it's a smart
political position for anyone to take at
this point if you look at polls in this
country the vast majority of people
really care about the environment they
want clean water they want clean air and
they are concerned at this point about
climate change people see that the
weather seems strange and extreme
they're worried about the polar bears
having no place to swim as the ice caps
melt and public opinion is changing a
lot on this issue and is not where the
Republican Party is on it so I'm
surprised in a way that Donald Trump is
taking the position he is on it and you
really have to wonder why he is
he's pretty been pretty good at figure
out where the gaps are between
Republican orthodoxy and the public on
this one he is not where the public is
well could be understood as misfortunate
accidents Jane Mayer writes Koch
Industries pattern of pollution was
striking not just for it's egregious
nasaw for its willfulness that comes
from dark money and this is a Rob and
San Diego this is a text message do you
find it hard to stay dispassionate and
if so how do you overcome those extreme
feelings regarding what you have
uncovered about the cokes manipulation
of our political system that's a good
question and because it's very important
if you're going to be fair and and
credible not to get too personally
invested somehow I mean you have to be
open to the possibilities that the cokes
maybe do some good things which I think
some of their philanthropy that the
money they give away to science and the
arts I have to say I think is good you
have to remind yourself to be you know
that they're human one of the things I
did I was really sorry not to have a
chance to interview them because I find
that that process definitely helps a
reporter even if you even if you're
regarded as hostile you you under begin
to understand the people you're
interviewing more on a human level and
so one of the things I did even though
the cokes declined to be interviewed by
me towards the very end right before
this book came out I went to Wichita and
I interviewed some of the top people in
coke industries I just showed up at an
event and I was uninvited but it was a
public event and the Chamber of Commerce
event at the convention this was this
was and I just bought a ticket like
anybody else and I've put down I never
hide who I am I put down my identity and
then I was with the New Yorker magazine
and I was covering it for a New Yorker
story about the - they're changing their
image and I showed up the next day I
went to the speech that Charles Koch
gave and Charles and David were speaking
and then
I went to a public event they had and I
introduced myself to the head of their
public relations and to their general
counsel who was there and I think it was
really really useful I got to sit down
for a cup of coffee with the head of
their public relations team and you know
I think it's it humanized them a little
bit and so you're talking about how do
you manage to be dispassionate I think
it's really important to realize these
are people they have a strong point of
view they have a right to have a strong
point of view there you know there's a
difference between doing illegal things
like polluting which I think are you
know something you can't condone but
having a really strong and maybe extreme
point of view in American politics
that's a legal thing you can do and it's
good to see that these are just people
so I was really glad to actually have
had a chance to talk to them it was off
the record but I mean it helped a lot I
think and I hope it helped them a little
bit because I'm sure they have a very
you know demonic sense of me as well so
Cathy's out in Santa Barbara hi Cathy
hi Jane thank you so much for coming on
you're talking about the Koch brothers
starting a campaign or an investigation
trying to get dirt about you and the
idea that if they can't find something
they'll make something up it's so
reminiscent of Nixon's paranoia and
Donald Segretti dirty tricks I mean it's
like exactly the same thing and you
mentioned that they have worked in state
legislatures and even in city politics
trying to influence state elections and
you are a pretty heavyweight journalist
with the New York Times in The New
Yorker but what happens to a reporter
writing for a small website or a small
newspaper who's investigating these
tactics that are going on at the state
level somebody who doesn't have maybe
the kind of protections that you do or
whatever are they doing that too small
smaller newspaper reporters as well and
what happens to those people
all right that's Kathy they they
actually have for awhile been pushing
back very hard
at all kinds of reporters they had
something they put up called coke facts
where they would do things like publish
private emails that took place between
the reporter and the company trying to
ask questions back and forth to try to
embarrass the reporters and and just
generally try to undermine reporters
they've gone after a reporter at
something called climate news that was
in a very personal way I mean it's you
sense excuse me when you take them on
that you are up against a very very
powerful bunch of people with that much
money they can bring lawsuits they could
do you know pretty much a lot of a lot
to cause trouble to a reporter but I do
think reporters have something that in
their quiver that is very powerful also
which is the ability to write publicly
and so what I did in my book is write
about how they came after me and I got
the information I confirmed it I called
the guy called Howard safer who was the
private investigator who was hired at
the time by the by somebody connected
with Koch Industries and and exposed it
exposing them is a very powerful tool
you know the truth and actually I quote
somebody in this book there was a
somebody who used to work for Koch
Industries who then in a trial testified
against them about their behavior and
about what he said was was really
misbehavior by them and I and he said I
asked him weren't you scared to do that
and he said yes but we had something
that was stronger a weapon that was
stronger than the coax and I said to him
his name is Phil DuBose he's in here I
said Phil so what was that weapon that's
stronger than the coax he said the truth
so reporters can tell the truth and I
think that that's very powerful Henry
Holt is your publisher I believe the
deterrent for dark money no Doubleday is
by public Doubleday at W
yeah they're gonna kill me because I
need fantastic editor we work with all
the publishers so sorry about that
double like what kind of fact-checking
oh so much injecting lawyering went into
a book like this a lot you know and and
we're proud of it at the end at The New
Yorker we're very proud of it too I I
went through not just first of all
fantastic copy editing I have to say by
doubleday they went through it with a
fine-tooth comb and they fact checked so
well it was it was people say that
publishers don't edit anymore that is so
not true on this book they edited
beautifully at every level but in
addition I hired an assistant who was
fresh out of Harvard where his brain
cells were still working well and uh and
he he went through the whole book with
me very very carefully he his name's
Andrew pro copies now at Fox and he did
a beautiful job researching and then I
hired another round of fact-checkers who
had worked at The New Yorker who are
spectacular and they went through it too
and and then I'm married I'm glad to say
to someone named Bill Hamilton who is
now the Washington editor of the New
York Times and he was heroic in terms of
going through this too I mean we took
off a week we were supposed to be on
vacation and we sat there in the living
room going through every paragraph of
this book together so I mean we did
everything we could
I noticed readers still every now and
then write in and they say you know you
described something as happening in the
Roman Empire it was not the Roman Empire
it was the Roman Republic and so then I
make note of anything that's wrong send
it to the publisher so that for future
editions we will fix it and we want it
to be perfect and we've done everything
we can we're human inevitably in four
hundred and fifty pages there will be
things that aren't right but I tried
everything I can do and dark money by
Jane Mayer was published by doubleday
Steven is in Woodland Hills California I
Steve
stiva has has a male editor who was
doing his job ever been fired for being
too abrasive would your good friend Jill
Abramson who I assume was doing her job
would she have been fired
if she was a male well I mean I have to
say her predecessor at the New York
Times Hal Raines was pushed out right
before her so it's not as if male
editors necessarily don't come under
scrutiny - and and partly what I think
that the the brief was against Hal
Raines who was a very talented writer
but I think that there was something
about the way he handled people that
became big issue in addition to the fact
that there was a reporting scandal that
took place at the at the paper at the
time and and and and it was the way that
Jill handled people that then became the
issue for her but at least according to
them so I do think I think all these
jobs you reach the top you're under huge
scrutiny these news organizations now
are struggling to survive and so there's
a lot of criticism of everything they do
that doesn't succeed they're blamed
personally for at the top it's hard to
have these jobs and so you know so I
don't I'm not at the Times I you know I
think it's a shame what happened to Jill
Jill is really truly one of the most
talented and smartest journalists I know
and I think she put out a fantastic
newspaper so the reporting was really
really good and I don't think anybody
thought otherwise about the reporting
and so I don't know I mean I just don't
know it we you know all I can say is I
think it's it's tough for everybody
these days and journalism at the top and
she's at Harvard now she's at Harvard
now she's teaching she's writing a book
and she has talked a little bit about it
herself and she's said that she feels
she didn't listen
to people who were around her at the
time so I mean she's smart enough to
realize none of us is completely perfect
or bulletproof that said I still think
at this point it's hard especially I'm
not going to say it necessarily in
journalism but I think this whole issue
of how women can be bosses without being
accused of being bossy is not solved I
think it's it's a it's something we're
working through and I don't think we've
reached the other side on it yet next
call for Jane Mayer is Marjory in Pratt
West Virginia Marjory please go ahead hi
excuse me I'd like to go back to the
issue about the Republican domination in
some of our legislators because here in
West Virginia we've had what some of us
believe is our own infamous corporate
head name Don Blankenship and many of us
also believe he's responsible for the
deaths of the 29 coal miners who died a
few years ago thankfully he was found
guilty in a federal trial and could be
facing jail time however in an event to
stop families of miners from suing in
the event of another coal mine disaster
a recently elected Republican
legislature sponsored a bill giving
immunity for these corporate heads where
they cannot be sued and be held
accountable by surviving family members
a few years ago we had our own water
crisis here in West Virginia where
freedom industries a chemical company
leaked chemicals into our drinking water
supplied then the then Democrat
democratically had legislators passed a
bill that ordered inspections of these
kimmel chemical containers when the
Republicans gained control of both
houses for the first time in 83 years
they said it was too costly to pay for
the inspection so the bill was dropped
and finally we got a democratically
elected legislature here who became a
Republican the day after he was elected
then he quit his job at the legislature
to go work for the NRA he's changing
from Democrat to Republican gay
the Republicans that majority that
they've had I fear that the that if this
these stories don't get out nationally
particularly the one about the immunity
that this could spread to other state
legislators giving corporate CEOs who
are not responsible who are negligence
immunity all right Marjorie we're gonna
we're gonna leave it there and see if ms
mayor has a comment for you well you
know it's interesting to talk to someone
from West Virginia because it is a state
where an awful lot of money from Koch
Industries and from the Koch
Foundation's
is flowing they've got a very big
program their funding at West Virginia
State University and they've got a lot
of money going into a fight right there
now about the right-to-work law that's
being debated there so-called
right-to-work law kind of in something
that make it's makes it harder for
people to join unions I don't know
whether their money is involved in this
liability fight particularly but I it is
again a state where there's been a very
big amount of influence by the cokes and
by the donor group that they've got and
it's a poor state and it is a great
illustration of how super wealthy donors
can pack a super big punch in a poor
state money goes so far and it can make
so much difference in things like state
legislative races so it's a it's a it's
it's it's very interesting they've
played very hard in West Virginia and
they're having a big impact I think
Kevin Grace has posted on our Facebook
page and there's a couple of comments I
want to read but it kind of goes to our
issue of heroes and villains and black
and white shades of gray in between
given the money spent on our liberal
programming public education liberal
University professors and institutions
and liberal journalists like Miz mayor
and the New Yorker it's strange that
their opposition to the Koch money would
be worthy of such paranoia of psychotic
proportions he goes on to say that
coke industries employs 60,000 employees
mostly blue-collar and oh no unionized
are they still evil well as your caller
maybe did or didn't hear I don't use
where it's like evil to describe these
people I describe them as people who
have views that are far outside of the
American mainstream where they are
imposing their views on the American
mainstream by dint of their huge wealth
and spending their fortune so it's it's
you know I
this is simplistic and cartoonish to be
talking about evil like that I you know
so what can I say
John posts on our Facebook in your eyes
is Dick Cheney a criminal and should he
be prosecuted you know I don't I there
was actually and the III there has been
debate even almost serious debate about
whether someone should be prosecuted for
the torture of the the 9/11 suspects and
you know I don't think probably I'm
again I'm a reporter so I'm not an
advocate particularly but I see these as
political problems that need to be
solved with political answers i I think
these are policy debates to have I think
they're really important policy debates
and I I don't think I sort of imagine
after years of covering politics in
Washington that if somebody brought
charges against Vice President Cheney
the backlash would be so intense that
everybody practically would be on
Cheney's side I don't think it would be
a particularly useful thing to do this
is Mary as a union stagehand this is
Twitter as a union stagehand who makes a
living from the Arts
I'm extremely conflicted about Koch
support for arts organizations and
theatres you know and I think a lot of
people in New York feel that way because
David Koch has put a lot of money into
Lincoln Center and into the Museum of
Modern Art I don't think you know I
can't say that I'm against giving money
to the
arts I come from a family of artists and
I come from New York and I come from a
family that gave a lot of money to the
Metropolitan Museum itself so these are
things that I regard as as as you know
the good side on the ledger here I think
it's great also that that David Koch
gives money to scientific research but
on cancer but giving money to cancer
research is good causing people cancer
is not so good
and they don't really talk about that
side of what their business does I mean
in the arts I think it's sort of
stepping back it's a little bit of a
shame that that the culture world has to
wait for handouts in order to be able to
provide culture in Europe they don't
fund it that way it's not just reliant
on on rich people giving out handouts
the the government actually funds a lot
of the arts in Europe and they have
fantastic museums that don't seem to be
struggling so I mean there are other
ways we could be doing this but I can
see why the conflict next call for Jane
Mayer Sheila Norwalk Connecticut hi
Sheila oh hi Peter and Jane my question
to you Jane is do you believe we the
people as a united front can get rid of
all the pomp and circumstances I call
them these delegates and super-delegates
they're supposed to be so-called
necessities in quote I've given them
quotes before a nomination is decided
where they have all the power I feel
that this way if we get rid of them it
will give Bernie Sanders a fair chance
to win the nomination based solely on
the popular vote and I thought about
this Jane and I to me an election has to
use the same analogy as when building a
house when you build a house you have to
start with a strong foundation if you
want the house to be able to withstand
all the pressures it will undergo while
being built and to me the only way
bernie is going to win the Democratic
nomination is if we're the people that
this election is
is has to be based on solely the popular
vote and I can't comprehend how we've
let the parties convince us that we
needed the so-called necessities in
order to choose the right winner and I'm
talking about the delegates
super-delegates endorsements electoral
college gerrymandering citizens I think
we got your point
Jane mirror any comment for her well the
book doesn't really get into the subject
of super-delegates and delegates I do
talk about gerrymandering and I do think
that the gerrymandering is something's
done by both parties but it's gone way
too far I mean it's it's one it's it's
it's it's really distorting the
democratic process and I suppose that's
what the callers arguing is true of the
super-delegates too I mean there are a
lot of mechanisms that have crept in
over the years but the electoral college
goes way back so you know III I just
think it's healthy to have this debate
the bottom line is it's good people are
asking questions I think Bernie Sanders
has brought up a lot of great questions
I think in a strange way Trump is even
bringing up questions that need to be
talked about in terms of whether the
parties have lost touch with the voters
and are serving only their big interests
the moneyed interests and I think a lot
of people feel that Jane Mayer in 2013
you sat down with Columbia University
for an oral history how many hours were
you did was a joke really I I did not
know it would go on for such a long time
I have two days ready for it at all yeah
anyway the thing is my grandfather Allan
Nevins the historian started the Oral
History Program at Columbia so I really
didn't feel I could say no but I wasn't
ready for that that much of an
inquisition they were very thorough and
is it accessible to anybody it is
accessible to anybody it's up there and
I think all of those oral histories are
I think it's great that they are I mean
part of the reason the oral history
program was started was with the country
moving away from the u.s. mail system
and written
there's there's so many fewer documents
and so many fewer Diaries for historians
to use and for reporters to use and you
know emails just sort of evanescent so
the idea was that people would then
leave this this kind of documentary
record and historians and reporters
could go through it and they should I
mean the Columbia oral history library
is very accessible I hope people use it
you're still kind of on book tour for
dark money at this point right I am will
you be doing the festival circuit this
year a little bit I mean what I want to
do is get back to reporting I want to
cover the campaign this is a wild
campaign and I've been covering politics
a long time but this one is irresistible
so I'm very anxious to get back in and
just do my regular day job and have you
even thought about another book oh the
thought of it is just too awful right
it's just you know this was a hard book
to write actually I felt because of the
fact that the people I was writing about
had come after me at some point that
every single thing had to be absolutely
right and it was an uncomfortable
feeling and I it just altogether I felt
I was sort of taking on very powerful
interests and I'm just so happy to not
be working on that right this minute so
my family said since I've done the dark
side and dark money it's time to do
something that's a little lighter so in
this trilogy we're thinking maybe dark
child chocolate no well from your oral
interview at Columbia University it's an
overwhelming thing to write a book but
what I started with was and this is
about dark side I put together a
chronology because this is really a
narrative I think the chronology came to
be 380 pages long right I did the same
thing with dark money as well a
chronology it is it's you see I had what
you have to understand is these books
are narrative histories really they're
stories so I think what I'm trying to do
is explain who the characters are but
more how one event flows into the
things have repercussions decisions that
people make in backrooms end up
affecting the entire country and so you
really can't see the causality of events
until you put a chronology together and
you do it and suddenly you think that's
why they did that I get it I get it now
and you see all of these relationships
that you couldn't see otherwise so it's
actually quite a fun app but you know
sort of exercise to do it it takes
forever but it's really useful when
you're writing a book so one more quote
from that interview this is about
landslides the unmaking of a president I
hope and this is you speaking I hope
that someday somebody that there will be
a revisionist review in the midst of all
the Reagan hagiography and they'll go
back and look at this again it could be
that I was wrong that you're too close
to the president and his staff and you
don't see the greatness maybe well that
is true and I you know it's funny
somebody has gone back and of all people
it's Bill O'Reilly he's written a book
that uses some material some of the most
important material in landslides he
references it landslides in the back of
his book he doesn't have any actual sort
of footnotes that that attribute the
material but we had a blockbuster
opening I say we because it was Doyle
McManus and myself who wrote landslides
who was with the only talks with the LA
Times when we had a blockbuster
news break in it which was that
President Reagan's own top advisers
looked at him at some point and they
thought that he had so lost it that they
considered invoking the 25th amendment
which would take him out of office
because he was incompetent they were
afraid he might be mentally incompetent
and so they actually had a meeting where
they took a close look at him and kind
of tested him to see whether he could
manage to answer questions and seeing
fully in his full capacities and they
came to the conclusion after that that
he he was he was okay but the reason
that they went through that process
was his own advisors we're speaking
about him as if he was out to lunch I
mean they were saying that he wasn't
interested in the job he let other
people sign his name on documents he was
spending a lot of time in the residence
he was over there watching TV he you
know it was a litany of complaints about
Ronald Reagan from his own people that
really scared the new chief of staff who
was coming in at that point in the White
House and that stories retold by Bill
O'Reilly in his book as if it's breaking
news all over again
you know I this gag assist shows you
that 25 years go by and everything's
reinvented but who knows maybe we did
and again I think it's a good question
did we who were covering Reagan in the
White House missed something by talking
to the people that people around him did
not necessarily regard Ronald Reagan as
a god or even as a superhuman president
particularly they saw a lot of his flaws
and so did we as reporters we were right
in there and they say you know no man's
a hero to his valet and maybe we were
too close to being valets but he seemed
highly human when we were covering him
Len Sarasota Florida thanks for hanging
on Jane Mayer is listening hi Jane
pleasure to talk to you first I was
taking a while back when you mentioned
about some of these people worrying
about their offspring becoming liberal I
had a little experience and that my
son-in-law was at one time the director
of the mellon clinic in Haiti after dr.
Mellon a nice philanthropist passed away
and comparing him to another relative
that family Richard Mellon Scaife who
didn't have anything to do with that
other than that I wanted to ask you when
you mentioned the time about the money
being given by right and left I noticed
that you I was going to ask about that
and you mentioned that 80% is on the
right I'm kind of news because in the
journalism of today we sometimes get on
this hand and
the other hand rather than the facts
like a portal one it makes it seem even
when it isn't and that's why I hear a
lot when somebody brings up George Soros
in comparison to some folks and
everybody else on the other side so four
to one is a little different than
even-steven finally just a question
about Trump you mentioned in supporting
social security etc but he like the rest
of the people running are all in for tax
cuts particularly with him the
inheritance tax and anybody looking at
those programs understands that there's
billions of dollars shortfall and how
you end up supporting Social Security
Medicare Medicaid when you have that
kind of a cut plus the fact that he's
going to have a military second to none
whatever that means
or is if we don't already have it I
don't understand the contradiction
that's why I refer to the Republicans as
the tooth fairy party but in any case
any comment yeah on that I'd appreciate
thank well I I mean it is interesting
and I talked about how these families
these extraordinarily rich families who
whose stories I tell in this book all
pushed for huge eliminations of the
estate taxes the the you people seem to
think that because you might be very
rich you don't care that much about
money because you have so much of it
that is not true of these families they
pushed on every direction to try to
accumulate more money and to protect the
fortunes that they had and they did it
in many many different ways including
trying to get rid of the inheritance
taxes and there's just there's some
great information in there there's a
good study about the coalition that
fought to keep to get rid of the
inheritance taxes and it certainly
includes the cokes and a number of other
families that you would think had I mean
they had tremendous fortunes anyway I
don't know I don't know where Trump is
on the inheritance tax I may be right I
just
having followed that particular question
ten minutes left in our conversation
with Jane Mayer the author of dark money
the dark side strange justice and
landslide she's a staff writer for The
New Yorker as well
are those articles accessible online
yeah all the New Yorker articles are
sure even if you're not a subscriber I
think so up to a certain point I mean I
there may be a limited number you can
get but certainly give it a try
Mohamed in Sandusky Ohio good afternoon
to you sir
whoops I've got a different line punched
here I apologize
I've got George and Lowell Massachusetts
punched up George are you with us I am
Peter I'm sorry about that that's fine
hang on Mohammed we'll get to you in
just a minute go ahead George oh thank
you Peter and thank you to c-span and
it's wonderful to see miss Maher on TV
with her book I think this book is a
godsend
many of us have been waiting to read a
book like this for years I did go back
to school as an older student to the
University of Massachusetts at Lowell
and while I was there majoring in
sociology we read other books like the
best democracy money can buy when
corporations rule the world by David C
Gordon as well as the the excellent book
by G William vom Hoff was actually a
conservative called who rules America
and it talks about you know the money
and as Jesse Ventura would always say
follow the money so I find it very very
interesting on that um your author today
on c-span has written this excellent
book about the dark money especially
after citizens united my question
involves a greater scope of this money
we're all aware of the Koch brothers and
and their influence and how they
manipulate public opinion to further
their agenda my question to your author
is on the greater scope
in her book does she talk about other
groups the groups that G William Dom
Hoff touches upon and some people on the
fringe touch upon but most people have
never heard of and the one group in
particular that I'm interested in
knowing if she has done research on is
the Bilderberger group does she talk
about the Bilderberg Group in the
influence it had let's hear from Jane
Mayer and see what her answer is I I do
not and I have only heard a little bit
about the Bilderberger group but I you
know I think I wanted to say that some
of the things I've heard sounded sort of
like overheated about it and a little
bit kind of conspiratorial about it and
this book is not a book about a
conspiracy it's a book about a very
small group of people with very intense
views and huge amounts of money who set
out to change the direction of American
politics because they didn't like where
it was going in the 1970s they thought
America was too liberal and they wanted
to turn it back from where it was going
they didn't like the environmental
movement they didn't like the consumer
movement they didn't like the public
interest law movement they didn't like
the sort of the expanding welfare state
that this it's it's not a conspiracy
it's a political movement and I don't
know how I would define the difference
except that it's it's you know if this a
lot of this was done in secret but some
of it was in public too and so anyway
I've read the dumb-off book I have to
say I remember reading it in college and
I thought it was great it was a really
helpful book and there is you know you
can never learn too much about the role
of money in American politics because it
packs a punch
Ahmad texts into you from California
does the evidence support Anita Hills
claim of sexual harassment the evidence
supports Anita Hills claim that Clarence
Thomas spoke to her explicitly about sex
in ways that made her uncomfortable
whether that is legally a definition of
harassment I don't know I'm not a lawyer
but I can say that
we discovered was that Clarence Thomas
had a long history of speaking very
explicitly about sex
he loved to see pornography many people
if you go to that book described it from
fellows that were in school with him
there was a he had a history here that
supported what she said and I don't you
know I don't know whether that meets the
legal limit of harassment or not it made
her very uncomfortable oh and it made
other women uncomfortable and there were
other women who wanted to testify
against him during the confirmation
hearings and part of the news of that
book was that there were other women
that were never allowed to testify
against him they were waiting in the
wings
there was someone named Angela Wright
there was some in the name Rose Jourdain
who has since passed away and there were
other women who had memories of him
acting inappropriately now you know well
at that point what was considered
harassment this was sort of a new
concept almost in the way people were
talking about it way back then now I
think you would find a lot of people
would be upset if their boss spoke to
them the way Clarence Thomas spoke to
Anita Hill back in those days there was
a lot of a lot more haziness and debate
about how bad it was or wasn't and many
people also wondered why Anita Hill had
gone to another job with Clarence Thomas
after she had undergone this behavior
that she said we had upset her so much
and so there were you know there were
there were mitigating questions but the
description she gave of Clarence Thomas
was borne out by the work that Jill
Abramson and I did does it hold up
20-some years later I think more than
ever really and in 22 years later 22
years later I think completely I think
completely including the fact that David
Brock who gave the who took the other
side has come out and said he was wrong
I mean it's it's a pretty devastating
picture what does it need a hill doing
today I think she's a professor at
Brandeis University
and she's speaking out more and I think
she's in a very comfortable spot and I
believe there's a new documentary I'd
serve a docudrama that's starring Kerry
Washington playing and need a hill
that's going to come out any minute now
few minutes left in our program Mohammed
Sandusky Ohio hi please go ahead sir
hi thank you very much hi Jane
I love The New Yorker I mean my I told
my best journalist is mr. Hurtz general
but your comment about what happened in
Beirut in 1982 means I was surprised he
used the Islamic terrorists thing
it wasn't even they didn't even know who
did it and now it's becoming so easy to
really everything happens in the Middle
East of what their religion no it
actually they actually do they have
actually named who the person was who
they thought was involved in it and it
was an Iranian backed terror group so
that was working out of Syria at that
point and so it's not it's not it's it's
not a big mystery really who was
involved in in that case anymore
and so I mean it's it's not to say that
I mean if this is not I'm not trying to
say something anti-islamic but but it
was an Iranian backed terror group Gary
Fox Lake Wisconsin please go ahead sir
hi Jean hi you're going to talk to you
I've been watching a lot of television
and getting more and more confused and
finding the injustice that's being done
but what I kind of look at is the
Supreme Court which is seems to control
a lot the way our nation is run and I
think that's a cause for the separation
of people and families and everything
else my question is have you or anybody
else ever studied the Supreme Court and
find out if the Koch brothers what their
funds have integrated some way in there
I know the
control the House of Representatives by
putting funds in like you said
supporting the party Tea Partiers and
stuff like this who got in there and now
they're controlling of who who or when
the Supreme Court and it's also gone
into the Senate that's where it's really
jumped up a step is just we have to just
be a little difference in the Senate all
right let's leave it there and see if we
have a comment from our author so it's
not such an issue of controlling I don't
think people um control the Supreme
Court but what you can see is in the
briefs that are filed in many cases you
can see coke funded groups are very
involved in many Supreme Court
challenges and you can also see that
they have helped fund the right-wing
legal movement the Federalist Society
and the law and economics movement and
help generate a number of the cases
through that is their money has
supported organizations that have funded
a number of the cases including the
Citizens United case there they've been
foes of campaign finance limits for a
long time and they've they've helped
push push push to get the law revisited
by the courts and so you can see that
you can definitely see the influence of
coke funded organizations in in
generating cases that get to the Supreme
Court well it's been a lot of the media
recently that the Koch brothers are very
active in criminal justice reform it is
and you know what else they're active in
right now they've they have in the past
funded a group called the judicial
crisis Network which is already involved
in trying to keep the Democrats from
Obama specifically from naming or
confirming a a new Supreme Court justice
I mean it's interesting that's amazing
and the reason I hope people get a
chance to really look at the book
including the chart in the front is
there's so many money on so many so much
money on so many levels so that it's you
you practically need to be a forensic
accountant to follow it and this is the
chart and there's another one in the
back of the block right here is the
chart on the opening cover of Jane
Mayer's book dark money and it's where
the money goes who are some of the
groups that are involved and you can
figure this out for yourself and there's
a similar chart this is the network and
this is the chart continued I guess in
the back those are dark money groups on
one side and they're more visible money
groups on the other side and here's how
that chart as well Peter in LA we have
30 seconds uh Jane I my name is Peter I
have not read your book but I've watched
three or four of the interviews in the
last couple of weeks and I'm curious
about an issue that I haven't seen
raised now you've mentioned that the
Koch brothers are very strict
libertarians they not only believe that
government is limited but that it is
evil do they hold that view also towards
national defense I suspect not and you
know what they actually are libertarians
about national defense they would like
to see less spending on it Jane Mayer
has been our guest for the past three
hours
1988 landslides the unmaking of a
president came out strange justice the
selling of Clarence Thomas came out in
1994 the dark side in 2008 and dark
money is her most recent book we
appreciate your time thank you for
having me
and so
you